see like a famous woman in a happy
relationship you see them all the time
trying to bring him down trying to catch
him cheating they want to be at the same
level because it's jealousy misery loves
company and so a lot of the friendships
that women have they aren't productive
whatsoever a lot of them are feeding
garbage when you get into breakup when
you have problems with your boyfriend
and you go talk to your girlfriends what
do they say leave him leave him right
now let's go to the club they don't
actually promote anything positive they
just want to bring you back down to
degeneracy I know my value people are
villainize me and I have villainized
myself because it's like well instead of
fighting against it and I don't know
trying to convince people I'm actually a
good-hearted person it's easier just be
the villain no absolutely not money the
love of money is the root of all evil
and so a lot of women are selling their
bodies and their souls you have to go to
sleep at night a woman can have equal
respect to a man if she is very good at
being a woman and a man gets respect for
being very good at being a man when a
woman decides she wants to act like a
man or a man wants to act like a woman
that's where all gets [__] up and I
hate that for you because you're a
pretty girl that's really smart and I
hate that you're saying these things
because you could probably be a hell of
a good wife and a good mother you're not
a stupid woman and I think you're misled
you're you're half naked therefore I
like that it is just so crazy and it's
so backwards that even dudes like that
like I I used to have guy friends in my
life that would feel like empowered if
their girlfriend wanted to go out and be
like half naked in the club and see how
on the panel wants to be married
um
feels like they were raised to be a wife
the man that I want can't can't care
about who the [__] I went on it who I
did what with and that's that's what's
really destructive about feminism is
that you talk about female empowerment
and then you guys bring each other down
more than men do you just compared
motherhood to breeding being bred like a
cat like these women have to go to sleep
at night how many how many women have we
seen Instagram models right now I want
any woman to think who are the Instagram
models busting it open that are getting
married what happens when if of all the
electricity were to go out and all the
police sort of quit this would become a
violent place very quickly and there
would be [__] zero feminists left 0
you would all need men that's the bottom
line of reality
what up guys welcome to the Jazz pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in as that is the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these live streams as you guys
already know if you have watched two or
more of my labs and you don't subscribe
we have beef okay beef people a couple
announcements before we start the show
and the first is that uh blessing what
are we what are we reading super chats
over today uh key call com uh
okay plastic wants a kick out cam um so
all the super chats are going towards um
a kickout cam which We're not gonna have
to use today I know we have a very very
good panel
um also
um
yeah so if you have any questions you
want me to ask the panel you can also
um Super Chat those
um we have four membership tiers guys
the first tier um is to be a part of the
live chat blessing how many likes to
open up the chat tonight one thousand a
thousand likes and we will open up the
chat the second tier you get to see our
Discord and our behind the scenes Vlogs
and we have some members only content
and also guys um if you want to see me
freestyle rap that's on the second tier
third tier you get to connect with me on
social media and fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month do
you want to know how to get a million
subscribers in a year I will tell you if
you um sign up for the fourth tier also
guys go follow my Instagram just pearly
things one um make sure you go follow
that they took away my first one and
they also just banned me five times on
Tick Tock so I do have a new one but I
haven't posted much on it but I'll start
go follow it just pearly things we also
have a new episode of wife school coming
out on where I learned to need bread um
so make sure you go follow wife school
and
um go follow our three talents now
amiri's channel
um Auntie Jenny and King riches so make
sure you go follow all okay welcome to
the show guys
um today
um we are going to start by going around
and everyone give your name your age
your relationship status and a fun fact
about yourself starting here and then
going around and then we'll do the
second row
hi everyone my name is Andrea odeya and
I'm 24 I live in Doncaster I'm
originally from Romania and the fun fact
I'm a single mom
hi guys my name is Esther and I'm 30
years old
um
a fun fact about me I am the youngest of
seven siblings and I used to do
Promenade so I've danced sing singing
and acting and I am single
oh seven that's why I don't meet many
people with like big families with me oh
okay yeah go ahead
hi my name is Mary I'm 35
and fun facts about myself is I love to
cook I bake
and I'm not on any social media
platforms I like to be in the background
and
um I'm from east London born and Breds
and that's it really
hi guys my name is Lucia I'm 25 I am a
model dancer and director and
um I'm single
all right I'm uh Brian uh 36 podcaster
I've just had to pull on my podcasters
on my podcast on Monday if anyone wants
to check it out very controversial woman
[Music]
controversial at all yeah there was a
few times where they were like I might
have to cut that
um what
uh making my debut today uh everyone's
lovely yeah
hi my name is Joe Berto 32 years young
interesting fact about me
um speak Portuguese English and um I've
got a very strong relationship with my
mother which is yeah cute I guess
um my name is Courtney I go by the name
Superstar creeper
um signed by Sony music and a fun fact
about me is I'm a full-time carer for my
granddad I make sure my family is intact
I'm just here I'm there for my family so
yeah it's just family and music so yeah
right
hello I'm Dave I'm 37.
um I've created content for YouTube I'm
trying to be a UK house music historian
you know something different
um fun fact about me uh I've read the
dictionary three times
I don't know if I've ever met anyone
that's done that Jamaican parents
okay
um so today's topic
cheating yep yep
yeah
okay so so my first question is have you
ever been cheated on and have you ever
cheated
um yes I've been cheated on and I never
cheat you've never how did you find out
he cheated uh painful
uh well I found out
I don't know it's just like sometimes
God loves me too much and they just show
me little things you're right got it God
brought you cheating
he was cheating because I think men when
they are cheating they they're away
um they they feel guilty and then try to
make it up to you
uh so he was he was like buying new
stuff and treating you well yeah out of
nowhere okay and so then how how do you
get evidence or well I just I'm not a
person that go into someone's phone okay
so far but yeah but it just it just
happened for me to see okay you saw like
a message yeah and I I saw a message and
then from there obviously I checked and
yeah and then like it was him like
messaging yeah come over or something
and no it was small
I can't really say it because it's a bit
inappropriate so oh it was like some
sexual stuff okay I feel like we got to
qualified question what do you mean by
cheating as in going the whole way or
what's cheating is such a loser that's a
good that's a good question when I think
of cheating I think of like stuff
that's like sexual you know I would say
kissing someone else is cheating unless
you're in like in a Range it's not
cheating if you guys agree to that you
know what if it's like a just a flirty
text message yeah like text messages
Instagram that you replied to something
yeah but from there it's starting right
necessarily not necessarily because for
me there's also emotional cheating that
if you invest your emotion emotional
energy in someone else that's also
cheating because I could be with a guy
and then I'm invest in my emotional
energy into another guy I think that
emotional cheating that's a that's a
woman thing I think you know like just
to be honest yeah it's a man isn't it
see men men when it comes to men men
cheat for different reasons from when
women cheat you understand what I mean
yeah that's why when women cheat people
say that it hurts more it hurts the man
more you know what I mean because men
it's like our penis is kind of talk
foreign
times you know and once you've bust that
knot
you're like you you snap back to normal
I still love her though yeah yeah after
you bust that not you're like oh you
can't what am I doing here yeah you come
to understand you come to your sense of
your senses no pun into it so that's why
you're saying man do it just to go bust
it or not and then after that it comes
in afterwards guys can have sex without
emotions but with females the the
different they need emotional very much
different yeah men can can have
full-blown sex with a woman and feel
less than a woman sending a flirty text
message exactly like we can be more
upset over them sending a text message
yeah than us having full-blown sex with
them yeah Mama broke it down from a
practical standpoint right this is
genius if you let someone into your home
that's slightly more personal than you
going into someone's home and women from
a practical standpoint they are allowing
you access to their insides yeah you're
just visiting you can visit 100 houses
in a day not that I recommend you do
that I don't do that by the way
so pick up my mom for that and um but I
don't condone it I don't I don't I don't
suggest you do it
that's it I'm trying to there's some
study I'm trying to find it that like
backs up what you guys are saying where
they asked like married men that cheated
if they still love their wives and it
was like 85 or 85 80 roughly still said
they did I mean it's not they they don't
they don't love them anymore it's like
maybe they want to try something
different it's true maybe bro so true
yeah
any mom says
that you just said of a married men I
remember being a lifter I went to go
clubbing with the guys who was in the um
lift and we see an older guy I must have
been around about say about 65 years old
and he was like oh that's you're gonna
enjoy like have a good night tonight was
that yeah then it was like yeah I'm on a
prom looking for for a woman tonight and
we're like okay because I'm married by
the way but I'm I'm bored he was like
she don't do nothing before me I love my
wife a friend of mine one side behind
every great looking and woman is a man
sick of shagna and I'm sorry to like
because I know women don't want to hear
that but like and it's not all true like
obviously there's exceptions there's all
good there's good guys out there but I
do feel like men we are programmed to
want to multiply that is like not it's
not a choice we wake up every morning
with a full sack and we're ready to go
and unfortunately for women if you're
not there like that's why women
unfortunately have to be on the A-game
for it's not fair but it's just the way
it is yeah a big stiffer on that one for
the simple facts of you can be
that woman for that man absolutely you
could be everything that he dreams of I
agree and yet still somehow some way I
can be submissive I can give it to you
as and when you want it multiple times
out of the day but the truth is if you
want to go out and do that you're going
to that works both ways no no and I was
gonna get to that point
um you know
to me it's like I've always looked at
cheating I've been on the receiving end
of that and I've been there multiple
times
now it does two things it makes you look
inside yourself and think okay have I
done something in order to
not satisfy him what
drove him to look at me but you're
telling me that you love me you care for
me oh you know you're my world okay show
me that I'm your world but then you
still show me that but then you still
feel all right I'm gonna go out and
demand him
yeah different area code they ain't
gonna know no it's not about that do you
understand what I'm saying it's the same
with women as well women I believe if
you feel that you have to get to that
point where you're cheating
why are you still in that relationship
why haven't you sat down and had that A
and B okay well I could flip it on human
too why did you choose the wrong men
multiple times in a row then okay no
disrespect no no and I that's the fact
because there are good guys though no no
that is a very fair question every man
cheats no I said every man has the urge
in them they're programmed to want to
[__] every day that's well generally
I'll answer because women in general
like men that she
is true it's true
like it's not like a good thing that
makes women look good but look at who
women pick like more two women have
always reproduced for every one man and
while there have been there have been
monogamy like throughout the last two
million years there have been monogamous
societies
um and the majority like of the
population has been monogamous but the
top 15 percent of men
um have never been monogamous ever and
now what's the difference today women
now are completely in control of sex
which has never happened in all of
history right and what has happened
since we've gotten in control of sex we
have been sleeping with a smaller and
smaller percentage of men so what does
that mean we could have the monogamous
guys but none of us pick them so
and we don't when we have the most Youth
and the most
because usually like we do go into
monogamous relationships but we do it in
our 30s because the average age of first
marriage isn't 31 so that means we're
non-monogamous in our 20s I have a
question for the ladies if this is okay
have any of you ever knowingly like deep
deep down inside in a booty call
knowingly I'm sorry have you ever been
have you ever knowingly been a booty
call like a guy who's just yours you're
a side piece you're not serious but
you're turning up and you know he's
calling you at 11 o'clock for good
reason like he ain't taking you out he
ain't doing all the nice things you're
turning up knowing what this is really
about he may be lovely to you he may say
all the nice things to you but you deep
down in your I'm just I know I'm just
gonna say no no I haven't okay I
personally haven't been in that
situation
um for each people or persons or people
whatever are in that setup yes what
about situationship anyone raise your
hand situationship never whatever you
every guy you've slept with you've been
in a relationship with 100 years plus
okay okay wow yeah yeah yeah you have
been in a situation no of every person
okay fine I've had any interests I've
been with you these recruiters need to
stop their game up they're too nice
wait what do you want
you see what he's saying though because
a situationship is the same thing no I
understand that is why you are both
single yeah and if you both agree it's
like if you know what the setup is and
you're like okay look I've got a niche I
need you to scratch I'll call you if
that's the setup then fair enough each
of their own but personally I've never
been in that situation were you married
you're married am I you're married
yes there is a ring there okay yes no it
just surprises me because if you're
still single at 35 I'm like every guy
you're in a relationship by 35. I
wouldn't say every guy that I've been
with I would say in my younger days
um you know when you're finding yourself
and you don't really
women sometimes want a little bit more
than men and
what I wanted is not necessarily what he
wanted but they sell you this dream take
you down the stream and kind of just
leave you there
and that was my experience right but but
that's still a situationship if you
weren't together no we was in a
relationship or you were in a
relationship yes we were in a
relationship and then he then went on to
go and find
what was appealing to himself and that's
how that relationship so he dissolved on
you yes I I've never gone out I've never
cheated on an individual but I have had
it happen to me twice
I'm not picking the wrong guys because
it doesn't matter if you're you could be
a really good guy I mean like what one
of you said where you know they went out
and this guy was married but he was
still out there looking for something
else do you know what I mean so
sometimes you can't really how how tall
were the guys how tall
um
oh oh
I don't know I'm like five two so
they're a little bit I don't know
probably six okay six foot and like how
much money did they make roughly well at
the time we were like teenagers so we
were all just grafting we arrived some
of us were either sitting in college or
you know doing a little Saturday job and
stuff like that we wasn't in a state
where
as I am now in my 30s where I'm more
established so give and take you know we
were still in college
degree or they're in college they got a
degree too yeah so they will yeah they
were working I have I have a point I'm
just going to read it I'm just going to
read I'm just gonna read some stats so
once once a man earns over 300K um the
odds of him cheating increased by
roughly 50 with a third of men um in
that in that higher income bracket
cheating on their wives only six percent
of these Unfaithful men report that
their marriages were coming to an Ender
didn't love their wives anymore not the
remaining 94 still love their wives goes
without saying that men don't cheat more
um or women don't cheat more when
they're in a higher income bracket
Beyond wealth the men who are over six
foot tall are statistically 38 percent
more likely to cheat which is presumably
just down to the opportunity
intriguingly um
University degrees are 34 more likely to
cheat okay so it's like if we're going
after the guys with all of these
qualities like do you think we should
maybe expect it on some level
if a guy's over six foot kind of thing
he he believes he's got more power if
you're making more money then that
female you know you got more power
all of these external things right they
only draw out what is innately in you
already yeah you could be a millionaire
and seven foot five but if you have
morals and principles and you genuinely
love the woman so if you're not going to
go it's just nowadays bro there's so
much options accessible there's all
these other cigarettes I'll tell you
I'll tell you why because if you if you
look at like NBA players like and
professional athletes there are women
that go to those games and seek those
men out trying to get them to cheat on
their wives like there are girls that
have said word for word I I it took me
years but I finally got him to cheat
yeah so so my point is even a good guy
if you're telling me some of the most
beautiful women you've ever seen in your
life are chasing you down hunting you
they know everything about you trying to
get you to cheat I I think like people
are human over the course of like a
20-year career not once yeah but if your
relationship is solely based around a
sexual experience then if of course
there's always going to be someone with
more curvaceous booty just around the
corner but if you're dealing with an
actual woman on a spiritual Financial
Physical Realm then there is nothing
that you're going to give me that this
woman doesn't satisfy me with already
and I'm talking from experience I'll be
honest before any of my ex-girlfriends
call me out in the comment sections I
Was a Serial cheater when I was young
but I've seen firsthand my elder sister
my youngest sister what they've gone
through and the Heartbreak that a man
was able to cause and it was almost
God's way of showing me this is what
you're doing to these other women
I can tell you the category
can I just ask you a quick question
what's the longest you've been
monogamous to a girl five years five
years but that's not 25 in the last in
the last four years in the last three
and a half years
in the last three and a half years yeah
I've never ever ever cheated it's never
even crossed my mind and because of my
line of work I can go on my Instagram
right now and I've got blueticks with
two three million followers ask me to go
to the Estates to have sexual
intercourse and I say no why because
from a mature standpoint I know that
what I want in a woman isn't just sex
you know look at your mother
it's so much deeper than sex yeah I'm
saying like that that happens but I'm
just saying like I think that even a
good man can do it on a bad day that's a
good point like it's not that it's not
that you're if you're in love not if
you're in love no that's it Martin
Luther King didn't you know he had a
stable home bro
every other day with a different one
thing I want to say is that um we'll
talk about these high Achievers these
men who earn over 300 000. those men
they they don't like that doesn't just
happen overnight you have to train your
brain into being a mogul and all of this
like you'd be selfish every single day I
think me me me me so any woman who wants
to then weave in with that wave of way
of life you can't just come up here and
expect an amount to change who he is and
be a different person because he needs
you to weave into his life and a lot of
women aren't willing to do that these
days you know and also part of the
problem is these men are like the alpha
males and I know that's actually like a
ridiculous word to use these days
because people have used it and
bastardize it but I feel like these men
like they're bred to be as successful as
possible to provide and also part of the
problem is they all want to like [__]
every day and they're like they're not
in control of themselves around women in
the way that a man who well actually I
wonder a lot of these men who aren't in
that situation are well like slagging
these men off if they were in that
situation would you have these morals
that you claim to have when no one's
trying to [__] you I don't know I just
think cheating is wrong man like even
though I've done it before I've done it
before there's nothing cool about it
should not be glamorized we should not
normalize it we're not I'm not I'm not
saying to glamorize but I'm saying the
last two million years the world has
been one way I'm not going to tell the
world how to be and I think a lot of
times women go into relationships with
like delusion no expectations like the
top 15 percent of men for the last two
million years have always cheated and
now you're coming in and saying well
he's going to be faithful to me okay
good luck my message the women is
conduct yourself in a certain State yeah
and if a man is cheaper than nothing to
cheat and you he's going to lose out and
he will potentially go with a woman
who's going to cheat on him don't don't
change his status and I think that
sounds really nice but it's not nice
when they can't replace the guy and
that's the sad thing is like I'll talk
to girls and they'll talk about how
they're mommed or their mom left their
dad because he cheated and now she's
dying alone and so it's like is it is it
really a better option and that's what
they don't talk
so you'll be happy staying with someone
that's consistently cheating on you then
stay with him
what does that look like dying alone
okay most women you need 2.5 million to
retire okay and and there's a lot of
evidence to suggest that the UK is going
to start rolling back the benefits that
mostly women are on so what does that
look like dying alone I don't know on
the streets being homeless could you
work it out with yourself not every
woman that isn't in a relationship is
alone they might have a family they
could have kids it doesn't necessarily
mean they alone just because now you
have to mooch off of everyone around you
instead of working it out with your
husband I would rather do that I mean I
mean I would rather do that I look at it
like this if you if you've left your
husband you have to understand and you
have to take and board the damage that
was caused now if I was married and I've
I've
brought forth 10 children for you and I
feel that we've built our Empire and
we've got our you know our tribe and
we're good we're strong and then
I was your world and you was my world
and then we had our children you have to
sit down and think well why is she alone
because the damage sometimes is in
reversible irreversible it doesn't
matter how many times you go and you sit
down and you talk to somebody and you're
like well this is what's happened well
have you tried this sometimes that's not
enough so yeah but who has to suffer in
this situations the kids no no and I was
going to get there and you know at the
same time the damage can be unreversible
so that's why they tend to be alone and
yes you're right it is the children that
do end up suffering because you know
they've grown up thinking oh mommy and
daddy is in love and you know they're
always together no no no no no no no I'm
just speaking on this you know and then
it turns out that that may not be the
situation now I know quite a lot of
people that you know you grow in a
household you hear an argument
parents do it all the time they think oh
the children are in bed they're sleeping
but actually no we're here and
everything and it does affect the
children I've worked with children and
I've seen the damage that it's caused
yeah but but the effects of a single
mother home are worse and every stat
will tell you you're more likely to
commit suicide you're more likely to
make yeah they're homeless they're 80 of
the prison population like every real
problem in society is literally linked
to a single mother home and so and so my
thing is like I just think once you have
a family it's not about you anymore it's
about your kids and so it's like this
you know this idea that we can't work
through cheating I just think it's silly
you know it's all about honesty I reckon
you know honesty is I think honestly
like cheating wouldn't be a thing if it
was for the honesty side of things you
know I mean depending on what you're
looking for see like in in 2023 now yeah
um even myself I've been involved in a
throttle yeah it's only for a couple of
weeks
is
[Laughter]
well I've got two girlfriends and my
girlfriends are girlfriends well not
currently it's not the situation
that's a throttle you know what I mean
and um
yeah but it's just a case of honesty you
know what I mean so I was honest with
them they were honest with me no one got
hurt how the [__] did you pull that off
seriously
it's like 23 of women are actually open
to that we're only six percent of men
are I think it can happen if you like
you said honest and open I think it can
well I mean how many women like do like
we all we all know a lot of women who
have no idea they're being cheated on
but like yeah like every guy is going
back to his girlfriend being like yeah
he's cheating like a lot of women out
there just have no idea they're being
cheated on so like maybe they would be
happier if they were just at least
honest about it and the man was like
I promise you I've experienced it myself
I've seen a lot of nice people get
[__] over and a lot of [__] get
great life yeah but but you haven't read
the end of the chapter you haven't read
it yeah have they died
so long as there's life there's an
opportunity for karma to be inflicted
I'm telling you if you are a man who
breaks people's hearts and you boast
about it and you're proud and you look
in the mirror and you feel more of a man
then there's something
there's something wrong let's play this
way put it this way right guys let's ask
this question get straight to the chase
your mom gets cheated on how do you feel
yeah you'd feel bad you'd feel bad you
feel bad about something that's normal
no I'm it's normally Society however a
majority of people cheat so it's normal
now no no I said throughout history the
top 15 percent of men have always
cheated women cheat more than men
nowadays yeah yeah regardless of the
statistics and where they sway it's a
wrong thing it's a wrong thing you know
what it is the side of cheating which is
wrong is the emotional damage which is
supervised to the other person that's
that's what we um fail every time around
you know I mean so when you're in a
relationship with a person that you love
like for instance I've been in a
relationship a long-term relationship I
cheated on misses you know what I mean
and to me personally it was nothing to
do with
um whether I love her or not you know
what I mean I just found out in later
life that I like different types of
varieties of Pom-Pom that's just how I
roll you know what I mean so but at the
same time that doesn't mean that I
didn't love my girlfriend
I definitely agree yeah not for real you
can still love your girl it's just the
excitement of another female it's just
the excitement and you're not ready to
be in a room no no but you can be you
can still love that female you're still
going back to that girl you're still
wanting to take her up you're still
willing to you
that's basically what you're saying is
as a woman if you want to get in a
relationship we have to expect the men
to cheat on us
foreign
you've seen like the top like 15 to 20
men cheat right so I feel like as women
we do need to take the more responsible
role of choosing better men because we
have that 80 whole percent of men that
don't but my thing is a better man means
and I've learned that like for the last
actual couple of months only recently
and I've learned that and that's big
from watching your shows actually and
it's opened my mind a lot because it's
just like we have a whole 80 percent and
we don't want to generalize men because
not everyone cheats right well and when
you think about it so like women used to
select for resources right more more so
than looks because when because we like
we didn't work and usually you would
live at your dad's house and then you
would go to your husband until around
the 20s when women started to go to work
so what happened is when that when women
started being the like selectors of
mates our first choice um is looks in
our 20s and so but what percent of men
do we find attractive only 20 well if 80
of that is ugly so back in the day the
dad would like like say oh no he's gonna
cheat on you stay away from that boy and
then he would like pick the provider guy
maybe we need to be with an ugly guy
but then women
are 30s they'll sweat because it's like
they need a kid times running out um and
so they'll switch from um selecting for
looks to selecting for more provider
first but it's like if you did that in
the beginning but this is the thing
though these these men we're sitting
here going right the top 20 cheap why do
they cheat because they can you have to
tell me the other 80 if they had it on
the table they wouldn't do the men are
just men you know like us labeling these
20 is [__] just because they have
the height the resources could we agree
that all men cheat them no I I think
there's there's definitely exceptions to
the rule like and like I think me and my
guy over here have a similar story in
that you know unfortunately like we have
this thing where we're very immature and
we mature later on in life as men I
agree so yeah we we go through this
period where like let's be real you want
to experience we want to try everything
on the menu you know we don't want to be
sitting 50 year old wondering what was
what would that have been like we want
to know and actually you kind of have to
get that out your system before you go
you know what this is actually childish
and one woman who looks after you has
got your back and really cares about you
is the real deal but you're not going to
come to that when you're in your
childish state of mind so yeah we have
to go through that and unfortunately
some of you girls are victims during
that period and that's yeah it's
collateral but yeah some things like
women like we should note we're getting
ourselves into like if you go for the
guy that's rich he's got money he's tall
like you know it's a it's a strong
possibility he's gonna do that so what
are you gonna do if he does don't have a
kid and then cry cheating later if you
know that's going to be a possibility
facts because girls are going Central
London for instance they're looking for
the guy with the lambo they're looking
for guys with a Mercedes they want a guy
with this this these big chains I've
seen it all the time
don't cry over this
question though so girls you you girls
um like men are only as faithful as
their options but are women really any
different like let's let's say you meet
two guys at the same time one guy's
sweet and lovely and the other guy has
all of these things you are gonna also
be a bit more drawn like to this guy
who's the provider the the alpha
accessible
this day and age I think I feel like you
know years ago wasn't so much accessible
well judging by Instagram and the way
women post anything that is like like
I've sat in restaurants before where a
woman has literally had a guy taking
pictures of her eating her [__]
dinner for 15 [__] minutes wondering
why is she taking a picture in this
restaurant because she wants everyone to
know what restaurant she's in and he's
the one paying for it and he's getting
laid-based off of that so let's act like
women don't value this because it's
literally all over London every week but
what sort of when we keep using this
term sorry it's really irate I mean
women what what a real woman doesn't do
that my mum would never in a million
years go to another club and take a
picture and be like hey real woman
probably
it's what's happening in reality but no
but no you can't we can't speak of women
okay can you can we make a general
consensus that the women in their 20s
today are different are of a Different
Cloth than the women let's say in their
50s today yeah
the women in their 50s are more
traditional than the women in their 20s
please say to me like oh yeah he's got a
girlfriend or he's got a wife and
they're happily ready to break a happy
home I don't condone in that like I
don't condone no I think it's wrong
again there's all the emotional damage
yeah you know I mean and I I put myself
in a category of um I'm like an honest
[__] boy that's why does that make sense
you know what I mean at least you're
honest yeah and um
you know when I'm when I'm honest about
my my Marlin cups and whatnot
other women tend to be more attracted to
the situation you know what I mean they
tend to they tend to be more attractive
they first of all they go away a little
bit hurt and whatnot like oh Dave you
shouldn't have done that but then they
come back after a while and be you know
they're reasonable you know they okay
you do get a little bit of Pom-Pom over
there that's no problem you were honest
about it and then yeah it just seems
more appealing for some reason I don't
know if you're addicted to pum pum like
that yeah why not just be out here
probably and sleeping with a new girl
every other day I've done that before
but at least you're not hurting another
individual there's nothing there is
nothing nice I don't care
on the 19th century there is nothing
nice about harming another connection
that's what it is right because you know
you you're uh on the Instagram and all
these girls are after you all of them
right
so you need to tell me that all of these
girls who you are sleeping with not one
of them had ideas above what you had
because if I know women and I'd like to
think I do I'm like my man I keep it
straight darling I'm a single but they
think they can change me they don't they
don't they're not gonna listen they're
going to be like I'm gonna be the
exception yes I agree with you bro but
then the onus is on them I go to sleep
with a clean conscious knowing that I've
not promised anyone
my relationship is commitment right okay
I'm confused
let's go you're cool with me talking
about your your job yeah 100 okay okay
so how are you commit like how are you
Faithful if you're on only fans
precisely why I said I haven't been in a
relationship for as long as I've done
only fans Oh I thought
been in it for five
I have had many propositions from female
content creators beautiful stunning head
to toe and I've said no because I know
I'm not capable of you know seeing my
misses having sex having whatever sexual
intercourse with some other guy so I
know so I'm not in the business of
harming people and I know that some
girls have said to me it's fine I don't
mind seeing you of other um so you're 32
now and you've been on only fans two
years for two years and then you had the
five-year relationship before that uh
prior to it yeah so the day I created
only fans she left no but bro I was just
I'm just confused because I thought you
said you cheated before I have when I
was younger 16 17 18 every single day
every day I stopped I stopped the rate
the day I realized that there's nothing
so it's just a little bit like you're
confusing me because in the end you did
cheat on her in a way because you
started the only fans I'll break it down
I'll break it down okay right when I was
young and naive yeah and I was ignorant
I cheated because I thought it was cool
it was a good thing to do right
then I lost my job only fans presented
itself I had a conversation with my
fiance at the time and I said this is
what I'm going to do whether you support
me you either support me and we stay and
I'll do solo stuff or you walk away and
that's fine I respect it and I will do
collaborations she decided to walk away
I did it it changed my life I retired my
mom I have zero regrets but I will never
no matter how many people and how normal
it is glamorize cheating it's disgusting
I've seen it firsthand what it does to
my family this girl's agreed to marry
you that's a big deal a girl agreeing to
marry you and you turn around and go hey
by the way I'm gonna [__] girls on any
fans no no no no no no that's me very
clear
I said I was going to do only fans only
fans does not constitute having sex with
other people it could be solo stuff okay
like I put on my Instagram it could be
feed stuff so let's not go down there
right but it's but it's still like
something she didn't agree to in the
beginning great so which is which I'm
not and she left no I know but my point
is it's a little bit like hypocritical
of you to go around saying oh I don't
cheat like that's a horrible thing to do
when it's like you kind of did the same
thing there no yeah
can I say it again let's reverse this
reverse let's reverse this reverse this
let's go on Instagram yeah right okay
are you a cheater if you've got an
Instagram profile
I think girls are in a relationship yeah
people aren't paying for Instagram they
have a wank over you yeah I don't think
it depends what I know they get it for
free but I mean if I'm in a relationship
with a girl and she's like I'm going on
only fans I know what people are going
to pay for so I'm gonna and if I've
proposed to him we're gonna get married
I don't care if you're working with
other people people are going to be
wanking off to you that's going to
bother me so yeah but we had a
conversation if I did it behind her back
on a low-key yeah and I was like right
I'm going to change my Alias they're
going to use a different social media
account so she doesn't find out and I'm
a cheater I'm a real man because I sat
down I said babe this is what I want to
do and this is how I want to incorporate
you into my future my Five-Year Plan and
had she said she would have benefited
from the millions 100 but at least she
was honest with her honestly there is
nothing glamorous about cheese
I'm telling you respect though and this
is from an ex serial cheater my exes
will tell you in the comment section
I write the fact that you're honest
though I write that you have to be yeah
yeah I've seen you know what final thing
sorry I'm I'm taking the mic here if I
hadn't seen my sister break down I
thought I was going to lose her like she
was suicidal if God works in mysterious
ways that's why I said karma is a [__]
when I saw that my own two eyes I said
I'll never do this for another girl
right never so if I want to keep
sleeping with Tom I'm not talking with
Jesus
but the day I commit to a girl that's it
I'm staying and the day I don't want to
I have an open conversation babe you're
not for me anymore do you ever think a
girl's gonna take you seriously with you
doing the content that you do guess what
I don't care
I don't care my mom is retired and I've
got a lot of money on my bank all about
that obviously it's a situation where
obviously we come to a stage in life
where we all want to settle down and
just have that perfect female well a lot
of people do you want to be a lot of
things going to be alone uh would I be
alone I have two wonderful nieces that I
provide for when I pay for private
school I have my sister who loves me no
no I understand unconditional I
understand that family is different but
obviously certain people want lacker
have you come to terms with with the
fact that you your career May land you
alone later on
okay okay I'll tell you right the two
years that I deprived myself from any
social interaction with the two years I
was able to retire my mom and make more
money in 24 months than I made in 30
years socializing with women my
priorities as a human being here is to
provide for my family that's it
a luxury of having a woman in future
they're great but if I don't have
answers who cares no no but but in later
on in life
obviously not not bringing no depression
to the show but my mom recently passed
but what I've done is
um make sure I sorted the house for make
sure I don't know this stuff but
obviously the affection that she can
give me is not always a fiction a female
genuine female point of view but the
right woman will come along
with the actual genuine females
but when they see things online and if
they're showing up if they're ignorant
enough to base me up on my face yeah
yeah and how I made my money then that's
a reflection of your ignorance and you
don't deserve to be in my prison are you
saying you would stop it for the right
girl a hundred billion well then I think
bro yeah
really so you think it's a reflection of
them if they judge you for being an only
fans yes but no wait wait no no no no I
want to see the reflection
because to me it's like your morals and
your values and like what you put out
into the world you know what I mean like
it's that to me it's not a positive
thing okay cool that's to you right okay
can we all agree on the fact that if you
were born in a single parent family and
your mom was raising the council estate
you used to work in Tesco and you
retired her is that an admirable thing
forget how you got the money is that an
admirable thing yes or no
listen I graduated from King's College
University with a 2-1 right
it's a it's a Russell group University
to get there you need straight A's right
I'm academically savvy I'm a good
brother I'm an awesome son I'm a great
uncle
I'm a wonderful multi-faceted human
being if someone is ignorant enough to
judge me in all my existence based on
something as insignificant as how I make
my money then that's a reflection of you
living in the dinosaur era because it
shows that you can be bought and that's
the thing it's like when you have morals
principles and values like there's some
things you can't be paid to do and it's
not not a fact you're not trying to be
rude but I don't think you could say
wait wait wait so I I'm saying like I
don't think you can say oh I can make
any decision I want and and anyone that
judges me it's on them like that doesn't
make sense now trust me you see like it
doesn't matter how good you are as a
person if you miss his nose you're out
there clapping cheeks
but I'm just saying bro
there's more multiple women that can't
handle that that's not a reflection of
another female of because
you know I know many people that were in
your same situation and and they went on
but they just didn't take like to me
that's kind of a cheat code it's like a
shortcut like I you know my dad he he
was on the south side of Chicago he's
one of 13 kids on a fireman's salary it
wasn't like he grew up rich and he ended
up employing 200 people in like a
company you know and so it's like some
people are in your exact situation they
don't take the easy way out my only
problem with that is is the phrase the
easy way and trust me every content
creator is going to come to my defensive
I used to be and you can Google check me
an English teacher fully qualified I
went to University GTP the whole lot
then I was a managing director in the
city so I can tell you I've done the
social norms and running a successful
only fans account is 10. listen to 10
times harder than being a fully
qualified English teacher
so when I hear phrases like you talk
it's not an easy way okay but it's
easier than okay so it's easier than
it's selling sex is easier than not
selling sex sex is the easiest sell um
if I wanted to make more money I could
take off my clothes tomorrow and I would
make more money and I know it's harder
for a guy so it's not necessarily the
same guy versus girl but I'm assuming
you have women in your content right
okay sex sells yeah it's a question do
you think everyone can jump on only fans
and make millions if it's that easy if
it's an easy one no I'm not saying that
every single person can make a ton of
money I'm saying it's easier than not
doing it because if if there was an
easier for way if there was an easier
way for you to make millions you would
have did it but when you say easy don't
you think it's difficult having to deal
with like people's perceptions of you
family judgment social I mean I think
that isn't that difficult that's the
trade-off for easy money
but it's not easy if it comes with all
those complications is it it's like
saying instead of drugs easy it's easier
than the other option because otherwise
you wouldn't have did it no problem we
can agree to disagree on this point you
don't have to be in Union and everything
we say you have your point I have mine I
I disagree on that front that's it
simple
um who else has been cheated on
no I actually I thought we agreed to be
honest
um who else has been cheated on
um when I was little man
um for me personally
um
when it first happened
can you hear me
oh okay
um when it first happened
um I was in my teens
um it kind of hurt but then I kind of
got over it and now I didn't get I know
another man before people come for me
like yeah I didn't even have a man no it
did hurt I kind of just stayed off the
market for a bit
um kind of healed from what I went
through because
when you're talking about cheating
cheating is in different ways and
different forms and like I said when
you're in a relationship with somebody
and that person is selling you a dream
and they're telling you oh you're this
you're that and but then it turns out no
really I wasn't what you wanted I wasn't
what you claimed that I was
just go just it's better you told me not
babe
I love you yeah but I want to have to
love you from a distance cool cool I'm
I'm fine with that do you but when you
go out of your way to specifically hurt
that individual knowing full well that
I'm not doing that to you like I'm not
getting numbers on the on on the sly you
you know my phone's open go through my
phone I have nothing to hide because I'm
not doing anything inappropriate
and the fact that most people that I've
actually sat down and asked I'm like
well why would you like what why cheat
is because but you understand that men
and women are different no no I get that
no no I totally get that I know I
understand
because right now you're saying like why
would you do that you're trying to hurt
me but they're not trying to hurt me no
well it's just how they're wired I don't
think it's hard
the majority of the guys here are gonna
tell you what's happening
I understand that when you actually sit
down and have a conversation with
somebody that knows themselves knows
what they're about mentally strong
they've come out of their little boy
moments because a lot of men still have
it whether you're 50 40 30 I've seen it
I've I've got stories for days
um but like I said if that's what you
want to do do that but why get into a
relationship and this is where I don't
agree with it whether it's a male or a
female if you know you cannot be loyal
to one individual you'll be in a
relationship do not be in a relationship
you can be single and you could be free
to mingle all day long nobody can't come
and say nothing to you
what if you want that woman that's
that's the woman you want yeah but you
still just like to have the variety
we're supposed to be virgins on our
wedding day what percent of women are
virgins on our wedding day no because
I'm serious you're supposed to bring
Purity to a marriage right now that's
the exchange they're supposed to give
you resources and monogamy because
they're they're not doing their mating
strategy basically which doesn't screw
as many people as possible we could keep
you know being like part of the Harem
right like with high value guy but we
say no we're not going to do that we're
going to give you Purity and youth we're
not holding up our end of the bargain
today I want to give the other side of
it is that okay
um because
I'm not proud of this but like you know
I want to be honest you know and like
you know my mom's given me a bit of it
so
it's like in my previous experience when
I was at my my worst in terms of like uh
using women and stuff like that when you
know I was I was in my high value man
and I'll do what I won for years as they
say uh basically if a girl I had asked
to come and meet me that night said she
was busy I'd be like cool one of the
other ten will say yes then and like
that was none of her knowledge or
whatever at the time but she just wasn't
there and my selfishness and my
childishness was just like cool I'll
just go through the list the first one
to say yes it's your lucky day let's
let's go and uh and and in my head I'm
like if you're not dedicated enough to
me to be here then you can't have any
complaints that's the way I was feeling
at the time and I think a lot of men go
through that when you're not living
together in heavy serious but it's it's
dating and I was just like okay the
first one to say yes that's it then so
question for you quickly have you been
on the receiving end of being cheated
yeah yeah it was awkward that one yeah
there you go yeah
Israel
I was I was 19 and I remember looking
through her text message saying another
guy who was like uh uh like I knew from
a friend as well and he and a funny old
thing is like uh we bumped into each
other in a bar about a year later
because he he found out the hardware uh
whose girlfriend or who whose girlfriend
uh I thought it was anyway uh and he
basically came up to me and went by the
way if I'd known it was you I would
never have [__] got nearer but we we
ended up having a pint and laughing
about it because like we just knew what
she was like and and that was the thing
as I I said to him like imagine she
could see us laughing about like what a
skunk she is what was that pain like
when you when you when you went through
the phone oh when I was I was 19 it hit
me right now because it was you being
faithful at the time
I was getting the butt home you know
what I mean I was struggling at the time
but was you Faithful after all I was I
was more than faithful I was like you
know when you're like in like you're
like she's the best thing I've ever
thought you know what I mean and he's
like did that change yeah
and I was like and [__] women yeah yeah
but obviously like you get over it but
that was that was 19. it put you in a
space for a moment where you felt
a certain type of way
or did you are you not the thing that
got me to wake up and not treat uh ever
again was seeing uh the pain it caused
when I did do that and it made me go uh
yeah I'm I can't do this again to
someone like I really that's exactly
what that was it was similar to him like
there was that Awakening of like I've
really [__] hurt someone here and I
never want to do that again and like I
never have thank God but um but in that
in that moment
um yeah I was very selfish okay okay
can we ask you a question oh no is that
off table have you ever been cheated on
just accuracy you have yeah
okay pal would you have you ever cheated
no good pal would you stay in a would
you stay in a married relationship with
your husband happily being cheated on
would I be happily cheated on people
always ask me this
um no I would not be happily cheated on
but I think again that the kids are more
important than you once you have kids
it's not about you but you would accept
it yeah if I have kids you know and you
try to work but my thing is like the
limit for them to like go if you have
kids I'm gonna try to work it out like
because I just genuinely think that if
you put your feelings above the kid like
I just think you're selfish
experience right now I have a daughter
right I love her to beat uh and I was in
a relationship like a long relationship
and I've been cheated on right I tried
everything it didn't work out
I tried it obviously what would he say
though
well because you know there's two sides
to Other Stories okay I'm on the show
that's true but no no no no no
we asked him is he gonna say she tried
everything
I think it was because he knows deep
down and he told me that too but my
story is my story similar to you but
what was what made what was the limit
for you what made you realize that you
had to walk away
uh I know if I'm allowed to say that or
no but abuse
that was my life okay okay okay yeah
when it comes to the cheating thing oh
yeah what is it that actually you're
hurt by uh physical no but I mean the
same thing you'd be her baby no it's
sick because I tell you women and men
cheating is two different things we've
established but we both have egos
believe it or not yeah I know we like to
pretend that now women is from Venus
it's a good book right yeah it will make
you understand that the reasons why we
cheat are different yeah between men and
women yeah for men it's a physical thing
yeah a lot of the time yeah that's why
he wants to experience more probably
yeah I just you know what like I say
variety is the stress of Life do that
however what we'll see is are you is it
just sort of like a one-off thing or is
it an affair yeah those are the two you
know I mean okay see when you have an
affair that's when it's like that's
different right you know
some people would store class an affair
and cheating as two no they're not
they're definitely I said some I said
some don't come for me okay don't shoot
the messenger I'm just saying for some
cheating it hurts the person because
like I said I don't know what you're
telling that individual when you're
laying and you're doing your pillow talk
yeah that that's where a lot of people
go wrong and this is what I'm saying if
you know that you're not you're not
ready to give up your Bachelor Life yeah
and you're not ready to like submerge
that ego and say you know what cool I've
had my time running the streets let me
just kind of fix up and do what I've got
to do when you're having like you know
like I said when you're at home and
you're alone with that individual
whether it's you talking to a woman or
your woman talking to a man
this you thought say certain things so
it will hurt a woman as well as it will
hurt a man especially if they believe
and this is where I come back to my
point again you are being sold a dream
and you know full well if you cannot
commit to what you're telling me why
tell me that because you're comfortable
because what in a situation where you're
comfortable I know you you know who it
works yeah it works
you guys will say oh be honest to me but
you pick the guys that sell your dreams
no no but no
you can still be honest but you have to
understand you can't say I'm not going
to sit here and say oh I'm picking
people that's selling me a dream no
because
I'm being mean so if I'm coming to the
table and I'm saying to you look
I really like you we've gone out for a
few dates you know we've we've come to a
point now where we're like okay let's
come together rather than just call in
let's come together and do what we've
got to do but I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna just
say oh well you know
I should pick a different guy no because
I've been in that situation and I've got
friends that's been in that situation
where you know you don't you don't think
you should pick a different guy no you
you can pick a different guy but that
doesn't mean to say that you pick in a
different guy okay you've got some women
that like you know bad boys and then
you've got women that like corporate men
yeah it's still if you if it's in you to
cheat you're going to cheat
but my point is not like a very small
percentage of men can cheat so if you
find yourself getting cheated on cheated
on cheated on and you're the common
denominator it's like it's well no not
really because if you really sit down
and ask somebody why are you cheating
like the guy in the backseat I like
pom-poms
no I said I was going by what he said
I'm not saying all okay but that was his
argument right I like doing whatever so
what I'm saying is it's not about well
you're the if I've gone and I've changed
my my line of who I'm putting the energy
out there to catch if you're going to
cheat you're going to cheat okay and
that's how I look at it I just want to
add something and that's for male and
female oh look I could be wrong here the
last May pick us up on the spotlight in
terms of like when I got to the point
where I felt like I'm a man I'm ready
for the woman I'm in that right frame of
mind I met a couple of girls where I was
like I'm bringing up I'm bringing to the
table a lot and they're still coming at
me with the same attitude that they came
at me at that these other geezers with
who aren't On My Level and you think
that that's going to fly with me and you
don't realize like when I say I can't
believe I'm gonna say this but when I
say jump you should be saying how high
because that's actually like I'm going
to change your life I'm going to mix I'm
gonna make it so you don't have to work
anymore I'm gonna buy you a car I'm
gonna buy you a dress I'm gonna buy you
everything
if I'm literally if I'm gonna make it so
that you don't have anything to worry
about then what the [__] are you doing
for me because if you're not free Friday
don't expect me to call you Saturday
because that ain't happening and that's
what I was experiencing a little bit of
is like if you're going to treat me like
another one of these [__] boys then
goodbye yeah effects
I totally understand that but I'm gonna
play devil's advocate here good those
individuals hasn't actually healed
they're bringing in and this is where
we're why does he have to deal with her
trauma no no no no no no no and I don't
expect him to what I was actually trying
to say is those individuals are bringing
in baggage from their past relationships
and they haven't or some of them were in
this like I don't know you guys have
experienced this but like some women
because of the modern day women thing
like modern women they go to UNI they
live on pot noodles they're messy
they're slobs they're not like old
school women who would like like old
school women are [__] organized they
know how to cook they know how to clean
everything that I'm not good at they
come into your life and they're like
Merry [__] potions yeah
yeah
they're like more loud than what I am
I'm more [__] cleaner and organized
than they are so I'm and obviously I'm
generalizing and I will continue to
generalize
but you get the point yeah but that's
maybe maybe that's why men have now
attended to your propensity to cheat
because the quality of women are no
longer like my mom
I think men are more likely to cheat
women choose non-monogamy yeah like they
we choose non-monogamy because when we
have the most sexual power which is like
21 22 23 we choose non-monogamy it's not
like there's a man that's true
when I was in the situation they were
coming at me with this like this casual
attitude she's like I'm ready and and
the thing is like men when they're in
their Peak which is like 35 more are
married because the average age of first
marriage is like 32 for men and 31 for
women so women choose non-monogamy in
their 20s in their 30s ask for Monopoly
but with the problem is we bring less to
the table because now you have a body
count now you have you have Trauma from
your exes that cheated on you that yes
like now but and the thing is that they
don't tell women is by 30 your chance of
having it if you're single at 30 your
chance of having a child is below 50
that means we are more likely to not
have a kid than have one no and I
understand that and you know what I'm
saying is it's like I get it like like
you said you would like somebody to
match
what you're bringing to the table so to
speak like you know and I believe in a
relationship you're there to instill and
uplift each other so if if it's a case
of well done by the way because there's
a lot of like in modern day
relationships like it's like who can
take the most it should be a competition
exactly I believe it should be a case of
your uplifting me I'm uplifting you
will elevating together it shouldn't
just be oh well um what are you bringing
to the table like they're saying we've
done generation no it's not that it's
not in competition
I mean that's why that's why a lot of
things don't work
but the issue is the quality of woman
has gone down and the like because
there's a very small percentage of men
that we would even consider so it's a
very there's less than like 20 of men
that we would even consider give a
chance to yeah so it's like and those
men like the quality of woman is still
low no I mean I'm a very old-school
woman like I'm not gonna sit here and
say oh I'm a virgin and I'm this and I'm
that okay this that's just yeah anyway
but I'm very much old school like I I'm
sometimes a little bit more
a I don't know how to put it more mature
than my age if however you want to pull
it like I believe if War together I'm
gonna bring as much as I can as well as
you can and if it means that we're going
to start this road of life together
where we build each other build our
Empire have our tribe and do what we
need to do I'm about that and yes I can
cook I can clean I can keep a house tidy
and I can keep you satisfied but the
question is again why do you still feel
that that's still not enough for you
like you said yeah two questions what do
you think what do you think women bring
to the table that a guy couldn't get
with a cook a cleaner and a hooker
okay right
no no I get all of that okay no I'm
asking like what what me personally like
I said I've had people ask me well what
are you bringing to the table first of
all I'm bringing myself
second of all I'm bringing my
intelligence my whether I'm a spiritual
if you have a higher IQ you're less
likely to get married so intelligence
yeah
[Applause]
but intelligence could be taken in a
different form of emotional intelligence
you're talking about there you go I'm
not talking about all my IQs a million
I'm not talking about it like that I'm
talking about it is I've I'm bringing
myself to the table I'm bringing what I
know that I've got whether it's my
qualifications my um intellect you know
yes like you said all of those things
can be sourced and I get that I think
but my point is like the the issue the
point I'm having is like we don't have a
resume like our grandmothers and our
great-grandmother instead and so my
point is like when you're dealing with
these top percent of men which most men
that you deal with are gonna be top 20
because if we show you 10 men you're
gonna find eight of them is ugly just in
general so so it's like when we're
dealing with those men they have so much
more leverage than we do
and the issue is a lot of times like the
women don't realize like in order to be
with those guys you have to give up
monogamy and you know there's some
people that may sell you a dream you
know
like you say like no disrespect to
yourself like you're a beautiful woman
but obviously you're bringing you're
saying you you bring certain stuff to
the table you're bringing like your
education your this
okay cool but you're bringing that stuff
but you're still single if you're not
single you're still in the situation
that I was single nor did I state that I
was in a situationship but continue okay
so so what are you currently you're not
answering so it's like
even so just like on paper right it's
like you're 35 there's no Purity there's
no youth there it's gone like by 35 you
can't argue you bring that's the two
most important things to Matt like I
said I'm in a relationship and we're
good and more stable I'm not saying that
even if we take you out of it the
average woman 31 at first marriage and
overweight okay no no no not in shape
yeah not young women don't realize the
urgency that they should be operating
with by the way like is in like a friend
of mine was in a wedding the other day
it was an Indian wedding and uh like
there was several girls there who were
like late 20s not in a relationship not
married and we're thinking like women
from that background usually they're the
quickest to get married you know what I
mean so I I don't think and when when
I'm dealing with with what I've been
dealing with women it's it they don't
realize like the competition now they're
up against they have no clue that's why
they look at me and they're like like
I'm I'm a pretty girl you know what's he
gonna do they don't realize it's like oh
you're like I'll just spin the wheel and
just pick the name out if I want I'm not
that guy now I'm just saying that's the
way I was just to be [__] clean
I think if women realize the reality
that Pearl is trying to get across here
people think Pearl is like trying to rub
people's numbers
no but I'm just saying like if people
were aware of how I would cut throat and
competition it is and it wouldn't be
because you all competing
out yeah yeah but that's that's the
thing it's like every guy that we're
interested is probably top twenty
percent of men meaning he's talking to
five other chicks how are these other
eighty percent of guys in a relationship
they're not they find one person stick
with them
they're the subscribers
they choose non-monogamy right right so
so what do when women we take out the
men what do women pick for butterflies
right tingles he makes me feel a certain
way so what is that what does that mean
it's looks okay let's just call somebody
so in our 20s we go for looks meaning we
share men in our 20s and then at 30s
when we need a child it switches so the
guys that are in relationships are
getting the leftover women but that's a
problem they're realizing too late like
your Peak your Prime unfortunately is
when you're at your dumbest when you're
in your early 20s when you look you're
prettiest is when every man wants you
yeah but you're too busy trying men out
and by the time you realize you're like
this this is now I want to settle down
the window is gone yeah and that is
closed and now you're hoping that the
guy hasn't already been married got kids
and it's difficult women aren't
realizing why do we associate our Peak
with our youth and physics
your Peak actually be once you've gone
through all of those experiences and you
understand as a man or a woman who you
truly question for you would all those
men paying for your only fans still want
to [__] you with 50 years old Paul
that's the reason with what good
question
if he was 50 years old on early fans
would the same amount of people be
paying money there's only one way
that's true
okay I have a better of a better
question would they want to watch if
you're effing 60 year old women yeah
exactly
he showed me a bloody actor that he had
in his podcasts who've done something
with a 78 year old
we're talking in general it might just
be
and so it's like we're not saying you
can't get better as a person like I
think a lot of times older women are a
lot nicer and Kinder but but from a yeah
I get it yeah it's like who the uh
we're getting married at early 22 23 24
25 now it's like 30s
we value the purity of women you know I
mean yeah and and the youthful women and
that's what we hold um high up there in
high regards whereas women hold um for
men how much accomplishments we've done
yeah and men peak around 35. I've got a
question just out of curiosity right it
seems we took a relationship for you for
women what's more important a man's
loyalty and his honesty or his stature
in position in society because then
we'll be able to decipher how much
infidelity really is a problem
out of loyalty or social status I.E
you've got a 20 guy who will cheat on
new Monday to Monday twice on a Sunday
or a track not a [__] well an 80 guy
who's not so rich but he's going to be
loyalty what's more important yeah
loyalty
um for me it will definitely be loyalty
and a good line of communication
loyalty yeah yeah I think and this is
the thing I think it sounds nice
but we just have to talk about by and
large women don't pick loyalty when
they're at their Peak so it's like they
could say that but it's like when when
no because seriously if loyalty was the
number one thing to you guys if it was
you don't listen listen if it was the
number one thing to you you would no you
would be virgins on your wedding day
because you want to make sure that you
have a man that sleeps with you that's
loyal to you for to you for life but we
don't pick that yeah but I feel like
sexual education is not that into State
and age yeah
but why why that's the question why
because women don't value do it women
have changed yeah and that was the
ladies are a very valuable question
which I don't think anybody's asked yeah
if you guys were a man for one day oh
wow yeah you know that question
for one day yeah what would you do would
you go out and check all these women
yeah yeah the thing is
okay
yeah so you need to understand yeah okay
if I was a man
for a day
you'd probably want to be a man for
longer you wouldn't know
what's the feminist crawl out the
comments
okay is I don't know because I mean
I'm not about and that's the thing if
you've if you've just got one track mind
like are you just gonna go and shag
everybody no okay but you are a man for
one day what you can do in one day I
don't like you'd be surprised
probably trying
I don't know something but um sex will
be the last thing that will be on my on
my place
[Applause]
I understand
I don't know like four or five ten I
don't know a million times the
testosterone we do 100 yeah and so it's
like we will never understand how much
they cannot give it a try I'll give it a
try coming on your period and you're
real Moody and it's like like anything
no no someone some women are really
hormonal really upset about you cry over
any little thing right imagine that but
you're horny as [__] non-stop that's
what it's like being a month
they say most men cheat because women
their woman is not active enough but
what if she is then what's the excuse I
think it's just that men it's the
novelty the novelty it's a novelty you
know what you're gonna expect a position
don't do your thing you fall asleep you
know what I'm saying like I love jerk
chicken but I couldn't eat it every day
sometimes sometimes I want to get you
know fish the chef's special
is
for the guys that have had
a demon time thing you've done
no
now my pure image is just gonna
first love of my life Jade the only girl
I've probably ever amen
all right so listen this is serious yeah
so
um so I was always a good person at
heart even when I was doing bad
um so I cheated on her and I've been
watching too many like blockbuster
movies in rom-coms and I thought you
know what if I go and tell her I've just
cheated on her and cry she's gonna love
me and be like what an amazing human
being so I did that I jumped in the car
drove home listening to bloody
sit down right yeah I'm a man that's
what real man do open the door told her
oh my God it was the biggest person to
say come in like literally we were never
ever the same after that moment so I I
suppose the doggly thing to do is to
cheat and then have the audacity to tell
someone that you cheated thinking you're
a hero when actually you're not I want
credit I've told you the truth yeah yeah
they told me it didn't go tell you the
truth play at me if whether it goes well
or not though I think I've got worse I
did the right thing yeah
no the right thing is just not cheating
at least you said it doesn't tell me
then yeah but I was gonna say if she
looks back at you now she'll probably be
like you know what she respects him for
telling me back then but obviously in
that situation married with how many
kids four or five guys I don't know
about the amount of time between
like what's the most girls you've slept
with in a day I don't know wow
simultaneously at the same time
[Music]
like you went and [__] her yeah no
when I went Ibiza I did a crazy stint I
did seven girls in five days oh four
yeah five days yeah seven girls in five
days
no because I'm I'm like I'm OCD I won't
even kiss I've got this thing I'd have
to do like a six point check you have to
open your mouth
like if there's any lumps or dodgy white
patches
I'm gonna ask all of the demon time
stories but would you ever date someone
that does the same work you do yeah
be honest okay cool I'll be honest when
I first started this line of work
absolutely not because like many people
I had this preconception that if you are
that you have to be some form of
repulsive human being however
having met many a nice women with good
standards and good morals I know you
might question them
um I probably for the right one for the
yeah I know for the right one God I
don't say no to anything if you told me
two years ago I'm getting my willy out
on the internet to make a living I would
not just laugh at you I'd be scandalized
so Never Say Never I don't know
tomorrow's day so if anyone's work
looking at this man you know you know
you're not going out of anyone in the
industry
have you seen some of these guys no but
I'm saying to you I'm like okay okay so
what I'll give you the situation yeah
she's got five million in that account
I've Got 5 million in account she wants
to retire I want to retire babe let's
sign the dotted line we're never going
to do this again we're going to pay
someone to delete all the content as
much as possible and we're going to
start afresh why would you say no I hear
that but she still has the facts about
70 days yeah but have you seen the size
of my penis and have you seen what I
bring to the
tables
that is smoothing energy
you can fact check everything I'm saying
go on Google and type in my name I'm not
lying there's no Photoshop in this video
so sure every one of you girls is going
to be Googling yeah
don't know
okay so so you might date someone with
an only fans okay I don't believe that
you know I don't believe that you're
what we call in the dictionary that I've
read three times or [__] hold all right
I don't believe you're a couple that's
different talking of which I'm gonna be
doing see you next week with that but a
couple is someone who takes pleasure in
seeing their misses have six of other
people I don't take pleasure with that
however if she's done it in the past
babe you had to do what you have to do
it
so she's not active with other men no no
no okay no no I'll be I'll be hypocrite
if I said yes no okay sorry okay
um so most demon time
[Music]
I had a girl in a hotel and I I had to
go I was working late I can't remember
what was going on but uh and then I went
to a bar to meet a friend and then I
picked up another girl and I got
I got her in a hotel nearby so there was
two girls in two different hotels
I want to say like within like five
minute walk of each other Max and so I
[__] the other girl left her in the
hotel uh went to work had a full day's
work went back in the morning and then
[__] the the first girl as well again
so that was like so wait you left her
there for 24 hours so no like it was
like one girl at like 12 p.m one girl at
like 12 at midnight and then one girl in
the morning when I got so it was free
three times with two girls all right I
have a question what percent of girls
ask you guys to wear condoms
[Music]
no because it tells me that you're
serious about your health but would you
feel the um offended if I was to be like
yeah hey guys
I'm a slightly different situation
because I've got tests every month so no
but I'm just in general if I like safe
sex always yeah
I I can't like I have been kind of
offended one
not like I'm that guy anymore yeah but a
few a few times when the Black been like
no you have to put something on then I'm
like what does yeah what's she trying to
say
something it just depends it will fend
me in a way to say like I don't know
what if I know she's insinuating that
there's something wrong there's
something wrong right right so
wait wait what percent of girls ask you
to wear them
out of 10. probably
20 to 30 20 to 30. I'll tell you what
even I've had a female say don't put a
condom on they've said yeah yeah all the
time
do you know what I mean I was thinking
what you mean by don't put a condom okay
what's the most demon time thing you've
done
foreign
nine girls
and how long nine in one day
and apple and then I remember like
there's three girls from Manchester and
it was that one girl was fighting all
this I saw my whole life there was like
no I was speaking to him first
then obviously I'm young so I'm with my
guys even though laughing and stuff and
then the other girl was like I spoke to
him first and free I was like you can
all come true then it was three of them
they came then when I went back on the
Strip uh her friend was like oh my
friends had an argument with my girl
blah blah blah
um my friends had the argument with all
the girls
um she's pissed off she was like they've
left me so I'm like okay cool what are
you trying to do she was like oh I can I
will chill with you for a bit until the
fact that I could like call them later
just come back and then went back on the
strip and then there's a number of three
girls and another girl and yeah so nine
in one day you could have made money
from every single interaction
I'm trying to settle down
[Applause]
it already has it
I know
yeah what about you demon time
um
I've slept with a girl's mom before wow
I respect your [__] Odyssey
does she know
does the girl no there's the door oh she
knows now yeah she knows
she was okay with it [__] me wait this
guy's got away with it all the time she
didn't know at the time but I mean you
know later on in life just when you know
you get older you work things out and
you know like I say honesty you know I
mean we I mean we don't talk anymore did
you know when you met her that when you
met the mother yeah I would yeah you
wouldn't know I was younger and really
and truthfully if I really think about
it this was some um cougar business no
you know what I mean this was this was
some real like I know was it I
man's point of view I don't know if his
class does grooming or not you know what
I mean
I was like 17. and her road was the mum
obviously
you know if that was the other way
around exactly
it's still grooming yeah in my own I
know but notice how we're not as
scandalized if he said he was a girl and
yeah
how did that how did that come up like
so you're hooking up with the daughter
yeah I mean I was in a a sort of
situationship with the daughter and um I
would go around to the mom's well to the
actual house where it was and um yeah
just one of the times I got invited into
the house thinking that I was waiting
for the door to come down and uh yeah
she never came down yeah it was just a
mom in the house and she presented
herself I've heard this before by the
way
same thing
it's not a rare but you need to win for
myself hold on guys it's not a rare
thing of mine had exactly the same thing
his fiance
um yeah he was waiting for her to come
down I'm almost word for word yeah same
thing mother comes out of the shower
wearing a robe boom this is what it was
yeah it was the evening but he was young
he was like 20 years old so he yeah he
wasn't going to say anything
yeah do you marry her yeah yeah is he
still married to her yeah I can't really
see who it is
uh memories I don't know I've supported
him in a long time divorce papers are
getting sent off right now mate
all right ladies what's the most demon
time thing you've done yeah of course
yes
the men's stories was nothing
go ahead
okay they can't even fix it
by ten
um I have no comments because I have not
misbehaved like that so I have no
comment the flaws come on man you must
okay you're telling me I got four random
girls from London
nobody's ever done anything demon times
even if I had sex outside the streets
[Music]
you go girl yeah yeah what did you do
what you went full for all or just uh no
no just hand oh just hands okay that's
decent did he finish
yeah yeah of course he did yeah
[Laughter]
um
come on come on we'll show that idea oh
do you know what I know it's okay so
went out
um yeah I met a guy
we well it's no not at that not like
that we knew each other from before went
out we met him up again and then we all
left the place went back to a girl so
she's got like her own house and it's
got like so many rooms and then yeah we
just kind of did our thing in her house
downstairs it's not that bad mommy is
back because when someone else's house
like I think there's more to the story
but yeah yeah yeah yeah are you trying
to put everything on the internet here
gotta keep some class you know but yeah
[Music]
let's be real there is no way that none
of you go like I'm sure that some of you
are Innocent but there's no way that one
of you girls have not had sex with at
least two men within a 36 40 hour period
or whatever I fully believe that one
year is why you do this but yeah because
women's women's uh importance of their
purity yeah is so important yeah you
can't say it and yet we can and yet
we're talking about like cheating and
how we need to be more open and more
honest truthful no one's being truthful
that's okay
I have a question I have a question who
cheats more men or women women
and I tell you what yeah so everyone
gets away with it more men or women you
see for women
yeah but women are very women you're
outside than you're cheating you see
women aren't doing it I think what men
needs is realize on what men don't
actually realize a lot of women believe
it or not are actually willing to
work out in their relationship with a
man cheats like a lot of the time it's
just when a man makes it a habit and
shows no remote yeah
that's what girls say
what were you gonna say uh women women
say that like uh if you would have just
told me you know we would have been all
right and everything but women can't
handle the truth
I told the woman about cheating yeah I
told you about I had a plate foreign
I can't blame women though because one
guys remember some guy's intentions are
just to go out and get girls one guy one
guys have a fresh haircut is for that
purpose because if they didn't care
about their hair they'll be out but one
you speak to a guys be like if they say
oh I'm not getting if I ain't got a
dream I'm not going out the purposes of
going out to impress girls with having a
girlfriend or not but then you can't
really blame the females because when
they are speaking to girl they are
sending them a dream a lot of guys like
that I want to take you out I want to do
this I want to do it and then obviously
um does that mean they're not
responsible though women women also have
the responsibility to look and go
whatever his actions saying and you you
can blame it all on him all you want but
like you're a grown adult who can look
at him and go what is he doing for you
really and then you base your opinion
off of that because how do you want to
say anything to anything but girls just
get lost in the source and then it just
comes it just becomes a habit it's not
happy it just becomes uh how can I
explain it it it's just an ongoing thing
it just gets in too deep it maybe gets
two two months in three months in yeah
they all start real and realizing
changes from that guy like after a few
months never been in a relationship with
a woman we're three months in and all of
a sudden she got comfortable and all
it's a different human yeah
but the first three months and then all
of a sudden like she is ratty yeah
the first month I'm like this is the
best girl I've ever met in my life yeah
month three I'm like you're [__]
crazy yeah but no no no guys no guy's
gonna go to a girl
um and be like oh by the way I'm a cheap
by the way foreign
right but the thing is like women don't
care anyways that's a crazy thing felons
reproduce like men with criminal
histories reproduce more and that don't
have them it's true so it's like do
women really like ignore red flags no we
love them they ignore me bro death row
inmates okay as than most men on [__]
Instagram so Ted Bundy got a girl
pregnant in prison you didn't know that
I've interviewed a death row guy before
and they're like they're getting emails
all day yeah women love a bad boy for
some reason serial killers I had a score
here I could validate what they're
saying I had a scar and I thought it was
the end of my beauty regime I thought oh
my God and every single God I've seen
since they were like dude you look so
much more attractive and I'm like what
girls like that yeah they love it they
love them because you've been through
stuff when men have to like for women to
be attracted to a man nowadaysia to be
really attracted to a man you have to be
cold and the Barbarian you have to
conquered some stuff that horrible guy
conquered some stuff
[Music]
it's something which women enjoy when it
comes to men having a certain amount of
ego a certain amount of arrogance
absolutely you know they've been through
a certain amount of trauma you know
they're a little bit gangster there's
all of these things add up to make the
characteristics of a man that women
really and truthfully they want you know
I mean they they like okay I want a man
who's intelligent and kind and all that
kind of stuff but they also want a man
that will grab them by the throat from
time to time you know what I mean so
they do crave for Bad Boys yeah yeah bad
boys but there's a balance as well you
know what I mean
don't tell me your life
why do you think girls like like the
freaking handmaid's tale and 50 Shades
of Gray like you what's that Fifty
Shades
tale is literally it's it's really
popular among women and it's literally
basically the women get graped once a
month by like they like they're
it's like that's really weird they're
like owned by a family and they're like
graped once a month and women love this
show 50 Shades was the biggest joke ever
though the guy's a billionaire he he has
this like sex room it's ridiculous
actually I wonder because we're at a
different only I had a I had a different
only dance model on the show and you're
all welcome to visit okay one at a time
please yeah
enjoy the experience
I've said a lot of smack here so I've
got to live up to it
foreign
different only fans model that was a guy
too and he said the number one request
he gets from women is grape scenes like
grape fantasies
um I'll be lying if I said I haven't
I've had it stuff like that the weeing
the pooing the whole lot but what really
stopped was me is and I was talking to
you offline about this is some of the
women are absolutely beautiful and it
just it it baffles me I'm like you have
no imminent need to be here in front of
me but they are
High Flyers like I've got a lady I won't
say a name or a username but she owns a
Vineyard in the US and I kid you not she
sent me 250 every single day for three
months religiously we jump on Face Time
she'd twerk for me show me her titties
like oil and she was paying me and I was
just sitting there not sure one off but
that's a unicorn isn't it like yeah
there are really loads of women yeah
that do it honestly my split I can tell
you uh from a statistical standpoint is
I think it's it's 80
um men and 20 women but on my social
media it's weird my Tick Tock which is
uh got a million followers is 75 women
and the rest men so it's just it's a
it's a wide mix yeah I guess people like
five foot seven your audience is
predominantly man on only fans yes yes
it's just women like it's crazy I mean
because you know what the people might
sign on to sing to see him slapping you
know yeah yeah but the focal point is
always me like I can never do a point of
view a video that will never work
because that could be anyone's [__] they
have to see the facial expressions the
the exaggerated you know just check one
of my scenes if you're feeling curious
I have a question for everyone so if you
could go back to being 18 okay now
you're starting over well I don't maybe
you guys whenever you lost your
virginity like like clean slate okay and
you have three choices for what you can
do this time around okay
one person for life
one person at a time or one person with
a bunch of side things
one person for life I was dreams I mean
in school from Young we've been taught
this fairy tale you know the guy comes
and saves us from the castle
Dragon like we've been taught this as
females as young as ages yeah we're
being conditioned so most females so
young they've wanted that they want One
Man For Life they wanted to get married
I can't talk for everyone but all your
girls seem to be agreeing is that true
you've only ever had one
exactly well
I will answer from my perspective if
we're both coming together and we're
doing one for life
then we should be able to explore
our sexual nature with each other
but I think the question was if you
could go back and you were 18 so you've
lived everything so you do know what's
good yes no no sorry it's like clean
sleep you don't have any memories
but I'm just saying like with like if
you could if you could go back in time
but maybe the memories wouldn't yeah
that's not I would have choose a
different person me
imagine
dragons
not say one for Life yeah you what would
you do one at a time what was that you
could do one person for life one person
at a time or one person with a bunch of
side dudes it's not dudes yeah yes you
could have a main guy and then some side
dudes yeah probably that oh okay you do
the side dudes okay so you'd have a main
guy and then you'd sleep with a bunch of
side dudes yeah
what makes you think that would be a
good idea I feel like if you're just
with one person obviously you know that
person you know everything but maybe the
the connection between you like sexual
chemistry I know that is not that high
so it's not gonna work
[Music]
wait so you're assuming the guy you
picked like the chemistry isn't there
he's not going to be here okay so then
you want to have sex with other people
just in case just in case
I understand what she's saying man the
hoes hoes save a lot of relationships
does that make sense
do save a lot of relationships
can you elaborate on what you mean by
that so I can understand things about it
yeah so what I mean by that is you see
I might love my wife all right I love my
wife wholeheartedly
however she's you know she's been acting
differently lately you know she's going
through a period where she feels that
she doesn't want to have sex that much
anymore she's a little bit more money
you know I mean she's putting on a
little bit more weight and
um yeah you're sighting just uh takes
that edge off you know what I mean it
gives you it gives you enough thinking
time
um as well as that just just a changing
vagina can can really bring about a
different outlook on life
so when you had two girlfriends did you
still cheat
um it wasn't really classes cheating to
be fair because I could go out and they
both agree to just be with you and
you're going elsewhere that's still
cheating now no no they did they did
well they agreed to both be with me but
I mean I could I could go and explore
the world yeah why are you with them
then you didn't choose one you choose
two you like nature holiday okay I do I
agree that but don't be in a
relationship then now he's in a
relationship relationship with two
people yeah yeah so you know do you do
you eat it was all the same thing every
day you switch it up you know yeah
I mean it's not for me but I'm just like
you know lately take notes time to
switch out it's true story I forgot what
the question was at this stage
and some Cycles kind of I think I'm not
sure you have a dog how old's your dog
it's your dog right yeah is it your only
dog yes yeah okay cool
um now if you had five dogs I doubt
you'd have the same level of intimacy as
you do with that dog right so I think it
would be beautiful maybe it's
impractical I don't
so you'd have a main one but the side
like they would just be like like
they're a little bit level well you
could just have enough or you could just
have a main one make that your best
friend someone that when you call you
bust jokes with unlock that and then
when you jump
okay
who's preaching this but you're the one
who's living here
Steve Harvey yeah okay no no no no he's
got a point 100 but watch this like I
never treat you like you're [__]
cheating every day
he's gonna apologize I promise you watch
this not if they're single two-year
career stand in the celestious industry
I've done four count with me one two
three four collaborations I'll go on my
Instagram right now and you can verify
this year I guarantee I have four girls
asking me to do scenes next week I'm
super selective I've done four girls in
two years
remember we're just talking about
cheating we're not talking about
anything else I've actually disagreed
with something else that you said you
said that I don't think my friends yeah
no
I do like I do I think you're a nice guy
but you know I think that what you said
was wrong I don't think that I don't
think that men and women should be best
friends in a relationship I actually
don't really think it works that way
because like best friends is like like I
think men and women are meant to do
different things if you're best friend
with someone you have to tell them
everything you won't say your own part
of everything and that's the new like
age like you should be best friends with
your partner but in the old days your
husband was at War you'd be home with
the kids and then he would go out with
his boy like I think men need male
friends to hang out with I don't think
we're meant to be their best friend okay
okay and this is coming from someone you
know I was a bit of a tomboy but it's
like you know I just don't think men
want to talk to you in the way they talk
to other men we don't think that makes
sense
but men need male time and females need
female time yeah and I don't really want
to like talk to my my husband or my
boyfriend about the same things I'm
talking about in girls night like it'll
be awkward it doesn't work it doesn't
you know okay okay
I can't believe what Becky Diane and
Deborah did and then he's like I don't
care
we're at least with the girls they're
interested yeah but then he's not your
best friend because he doesn't have the
same level of interest and there's the
things that you do but there is a man
that would be interested in
not the guy that's interested in women
things like that's a feminine man I mean
I I I pluck my eyebrows does that make
me feminine I cry
I'm gonna I'm gonna answer um yeah you
know I do think
like just talking to you you know okay I
do I do get a little bit that's fine and
I think like if you're crying all the
time I do think you're more feminine
than a guy that doesn't cry all the time
but why is it not okay for men to come
yeah
when you cry did I say it was it not
okay I mean you can do it but I think
like as women we want a strong leader
and like like what we call our husband
like our rock that we want we want to
lean on right we don't want a guy that's
crying all the time
is the president of the country like is
Trump when he was in office crying on
stage now you know equally a lot of
women need to realize that you're not
like the president too you're the first
lady I'm president you know what I mean
like his analogies go that works quite
well I think there's like we need to be
different and that's actually a
compliment to each other and we need to
work together in that way and I feel
like as much as I hear what he's saying
like being close is a great thing but we
are different and we need to like come
together in a different way so you kind
of need to balance each other out yeah
yeah she's gonna fill in at my flaws and
I'm gonna film it yeah I think my best
friend I think we read too deeply into
it I meant someone that you trust you
love someone who you you are happy to be
in their presence and you know it
doesn't feel like I understand what you
mean of course we're not going to sit
down and play Xbox one
so I get it
you might be um save you girls yeah are
your partner's best friend yeah is it
okay for your partner to have other lady
friends
is he okay for us to have
no it's rude to answer a question with a
question
that's true if you think about it
um I would um it's difficult it's
difficult one
um
before I would have said yes but I
watched a oh what's that Harvey
Weinstein no it was a guy I watched
recently oh yeah yeah Steve Harvey yeah
Steve Harvey and he was just saying
something like um when male and females
are friends is because the woman hasn't
allowed him in yet that's right I saw
that video she had the slightest chance
that he could go through that Gap he was
yeah
that's very interesting you girls agree
with that yeah I agree 100 do you girls
have male friends then I
my partner wasn't happy with me having
male friends I would happily you know
cut them off would you but only you
would you cut all the male friends off
for the man
um no it depends because I mean you're
if you're telling me to cut off my
friends
but then you're still being able to yeah
I got your female friends then no but if
it's something that we're both going
into today yes if you're both willing to
do it I don't see a problem with that
but if it's a case of yeah you're my
woman uh you can't talk to this person
don't believe there's nothing so there's
no such thing as a male best friend
towards a female because I feel like
every every guy would know what he wants
and if he did put it on the plate and
say I know if you a female deporting a
plate for that guy and say like you know
what I'm fed up on my car like it's been
peeing me off a bit like can you just
come round and show his intentions
one of my first girlfriends she
convinced me it's not like that and you
know when you're young and
impressionable you're willing to like
let things go because you really love
her and all of that and then the minute
we broke up he was
trying everything I'm never gonna
[__] allow this again ever it's the
way it works I mean I was at a club last
night yeah and I spoke to um this guy
that used to be friends with one of my
ex-girlfriends and even he said to me he
was like you know when you used to go
out with Danielle I Used To Love Her Off
you know
I'm like oh word yeah he's like yeah man
I used to proper love her off and I'm
like this is this is exactly what I mean
we can't really
trust ourselves what if the girl's not
attractive though if the girl's not
attracted yeah what do you mean that's a
good question she could have a male
friend yeah but he might not be the same
level of service do you you know what I
mean you see like all the pretty girls
they're like oh yeah my male best friend
he'll pick me up any time of the night
and all of this kind of stuff you're
gonna get certain um privileges from
being that that good looking friend yeah
you know I mean whereas if if I mean
I've got what if it's a gay friend uh
that one's cool yeah so you're cool with
him seeing her butt naked slapping them
yeah
difference
yeah I've done someone pretend I was gay
just because he wanted to go on her
pants yeah and this oh this is what I
was going to say so you can't even trust
me before bro you see um that women
cheat more yeah but
see the men the men are more willing to
be more conducive to the cheating so
what's that mean
so what it means is I will I will be
more in a way to conduct myself for you
not to get caught out and for our
situation to keep evolving right so if
I'm gonna be a side negro yeah what I
would tend to do would be to save my
number as something else in a girl's
phone book if a man Rings up my phone
I'm not going to blow up her spot I'm
going to say oh no no bro I'm I'm a
cousin or like whatever it might well be
I'm gonna but girls girls don't really
give a [__] you see once The Jig Is up
yeah but yeah I told your girlfriend
yeah you know what I mean I told your
girlfriend about Arsenal but men are
more conducive
and a taxi together it wasn't wasn't a
good situation you know what I mean so
we we are generally more conducive to
you guys not being caught and if we're
if we're the side pieces we tend to play
that role better I believe whereas women
they don't really give too much of a
[__] they they don't mind if men get
caught when it comes to the cheating
side of things that's what I think you
know when when men do it men I think
it's a lot to do with a man's confidence
as well when I was broke and I didn't
look the way I did I'll be honest I was
insecure I didn't want my ex-girlfriends
lingering around other guys because I
knew they were better than me but I've
got to a position in my life by working
on myself for two years without having a
girlfriend where I'm I know me I'm not
God's Gift bro just look at my height
thank you so much
so at the end of the day
I do know what I offer and um
go ahead have as many male friends as
you no that's true but we do have to we
still have them in security I know what
I offered
person do you guys think it's cheating
as a girl to be posting pictures on
Instagram while you're in a relationship
hell no okay what kind of pictures what
really any pictures that pictures or
like a selfie advertisers
really because okay okay do you think
attention is to woman as to Sexes to men
no no you don't similar but it is it's
not the same currency you know I mean I
think that because we live in such a PC
World at the moment if a lady throws up
some pictures of her in herself in a
bikini she knows what the purpose of it
is you know I mean it's to gain the
attention however men don't need to be
as sensitive to think that that is
cheating
okay but this is why I think it is
because like women's mating strategy
from a biological perspective is to get
attention from the highest value guy so
what is Instagram that is getting
attention from that wait wait wait so
that is getting attention from the
highest value Guy where on the other
hand men's mating strategy is just screw
as many people as possible but when they
get into a relationship the men are
expected to stop screwing as many people
as possible but the women are not
expected to compromise in their mating
strategy which is seeking attention from
high value men and which is posting
pictures on Instagram because you know
damn well even if it's just your face if
you're a pretty girl there are going to
be you know a high value men interested
to your point I've had an experience
where I had a girl like one of my
photographs sliding the DM said hello
and immediately her boyfriend the
pressure that was on him in that
relationship went up 10 times because a
man who superseded his earning his uh
different ways yeah they're not going to
go anywhere because you know nothing
against a guy but she said afterwards
when I met her because she dumped him
the pressure was on immediately and when
women are doing that it is a for sale
sign to a degree not a pro you know but
it is advertising isn't it it's like and
men are flooding the damn so but if you
especially if it's a naked or semi-naked
photograph sorry but even like even just
a selfie and the other thing women don't
think about is like women will still go
out to bars and clubs where all of the
guys are trying to screw you men are
again men that's that's seeking
attention from high value men
the best guy that you can get where the
men are still ex like the men are D this
is why I I come back so hard on cheating
because we cheat in different ways women
still do it all the time and it's
accepted in society and so when men
cheat it's it like we do the same thing
like we do the same things just in a
different way that's why I asked at the
very beginning what do we mean by
cheating I think if we come up with a
better definition of people because
she's right when you break it down like
that you are right people are running as
faithful as their options and women are
ex like women are under the guise of
like hey I'm just posting a photograph
under the guise of that allowing them to
explore their actions whereas when men
explore their options we have to be a
lot more deliberate we're messaging
we're putting the fish in Rod out and
going are you available and if we get
caught doing that then we're caught
red-handed whereas with women it's women
women
that's what women do there's a totally
different scenarios what they do is they
put the pictures up all on Instagram
yeah and they just leave them to sit
there and it's like they're just cast it
in there
but it's like a girl will literally be
going out with ass pictures on Instagram
and she'll cry but oh he cheated on me
when i'm like [__] look at your profile
yeah and the women act like we act like
we're so much better than the men we
would never do that but it's like okay
you you go out twice a week you get all
this attention from guys you have guys
trying to screw you all the time how are
you better than him and that's the thing
like I just don't like as women like
we're just on our high horse like oh
it's the worst thing in the world that
he cheated he's such a horrible person
when we do it in a different way every
single day yeah I didn't think of it I
mean that's what I said before like what
what is the actual thing that hurts with
cheating for women because well I tend
to hear oh I say like I've heard it a
million times
what I've heard before is what did she
have that I didn't have yeah yeah of
course you had that I think that was
that that's the sort of thing which
women say
um and sometimes it's not actually about
that you know I mean it's not about
um what the woman has from what you
don't have because Jay-Z cheated on
Beyonce you know what I mean yeah and
like it's supposed to be the baddest in
the game right she is the baddest of the
game but she's still got you're trying
to but that was after two kids or
whatever and all of a sudden all the
attention is on the kids I'm not saying
um that this makes anything okay I'm not
I'm just saying like yeah when when
Beyonce and whoever all these women are
focusing in on the children and the Man
all of a sudden becomes yeah you're the
last thing I'm thinking about to do you
know whereas before when you met each
other I was priority number one and for
men especially if you're one of these
high value men who is earning all this
money and changing This Woman's life
that needs to continue or if you let
your standard slip there will be someone
ready and waiting to replace it yeah but
women don't realize that because we're
not going to tell you because what we're
going to say like we can't say that yeah
oh by the way [__] she was sliding
into my dates
[Music]
and a lot of times the girls like
Beyonce you think Beyonce didn't know
like you think Beyonce didn't know she
was getting cheated out like a lot of
the girls in these Arrangements they
already know and then the women will
come in and say they're doing the right
thing by telling them or posting it
online when it's like a lot of these
girls just don't well she stayed with
Jay-Z so like all of this single ladies
and Independent Women [__] she
stayed with Jay Z isn't the most
handsome man ever and this is why I go
back to saying like a lot of men don't
realize women are actually willing to
work it out if you have
you might deal with it a little bit yeah
I mean you're 25 so maybe at your age
like because there's a future right so
if you meet a guy and he he maybe
doesn't have a [__] figured out he could
start an of at 31 and then you know make
millions and then take care of you you
know she's setting us up
from Asda yeah
I'm still like trying to grow with him
right right but if he was but let's
let's say he's 45 I don't know how old
you did yeah but you wouldn't date a
broke guy at 45 no no he'd have to
figure it out yeah well I would say you
see like if you've got Tom that works in
ASDA yeah Tom who works in ASDA will
cheat on you one time yeah see you later
Tom but if you've got you know Kieran
who works up in the city in the banking
district and whatnot and he cheats on
you you might give him one or two more
chances but generally men are the Same
by the way so like we but not in
cheating but we alter our standards to
know other things depending on how good
the sex is if your sex is amazing I'll
look you'll tolerate a lot more Overlook
the fact that you're a slob or that you
you know you're disappointed you're not
actually you can't cook for sure like
yeah
but you know
it does make you and women do the same
thing but in different ways yeah thanks
I have a question for the girls okay
would you rather
how many how many kids do you guys I
know some of you have kids I have just
one do you want more I do yeah okay how
many do you want Total
maybe like three in total three how many
kids do you want how many kids do I won
yeah
um probably about four okay four kids
yeah you better get moving girl
I've got sub already though oh you have
some let's see okay so you want two more
okay what about you yeah
um I always want itch
more than five
okay
um
um I'll be happy with two one boy one
girl okay so how much do you guys think
it costs a year to raise
um the amount of kids you want
if you're a single mom a lot okay
um so so if you have two choices guy a
you have to work until you're 65. um 70
we're up it to 70. and you have to work
30 hours a week while being a mom
okay guy B takes care of everything but
he steps out from time to time but you
don't ever have to work again and you're
done
I already work 40 hours a week so it's
fine even now you get to work zero
I've been in relationships with being 60
40 my end and then we'd both be paying
like 50 50 on the bills and an Abby
cooking cleaning and doing the washing
and I'll be doing like grocery shop as
well but I don't think I could do that
again that was a lot
um but and imagine looking after the kid
as well you would take which one I would
probably say B the guy who paid for
everything yeah yeah okay
she's honest I think most girls would
take bees yeah I I would because I've
been there
I mean I'm just thinking like like so
you're taking the easy way out
because I would love to watch attribute
no I mean 40 years is a long time you're
not gonna have the same energy you do
but at the same time I do love what I do
and I I love it with a passion
regardless like I did it without money
so I still want to you know some kind of
control over me doing some kind of work
sorry what is it you do for a living
um I direct the model and dance okay
yeah I do like commercials like adverts
on TV and stuff I mean I'm not saying
it's an easy job but it's a fun job
something that you look forward to going
to yeah yeah
would you say out of the two options
that you presented that b would be the
easier way out it would be yeah it is it
is so we need to keep that energy there
is the easiest way when we look at only
fans creators and say that we've taken
the easy way
I like consistency as he said I don't
like Hypocrites so when he pulled me up
he's right he's right when you were
right you were right but if we're gonna
go and say that we're gonna go for Plan
B then please we can't have enough time
no no I'm talking about the bees in the
room oh don't then say ah you took the
easy way out because you've just
confessed with your own mouth okay if
you had the opportunity between the hard
and the easy
but I think in life most people take
this easy way it just depends it just
depends if it interferes with your
morals and value so it's like the thing
that surprised me is a man in in this
day and age is like knowing how many
women have to work these days because
when I was in situations where I was
able to set a woman you don't have to
work anymore I'm going to look after you
all of that the lack of uh appreciation
um
like within a couple of months they're
acting like they've always been this
yeah they they have like this memory you
know you are the Men in Black with it
yeah it was like they'd never work the
day in their life so women get
comfortable [__] super quick and that
that surprised me the more more than
anything and I believe exactly what
you're saying I feel like the majority
of females nowadays are taking the um
Plan B like nowadays that's why guys
ain't really taking them serious and I
feel like that's that's just the way it
is yo if you're you as a man are going
to a woman saying I can offer you this
and I can offer you that of course the
woman's gonna be like you know what let
me take that offer there yeah no but I
feel like them you gotta think of it
like this you're going to a job
interview yeah you're going um you I
don't know you you've gone to Starbucks
for instance Starbucks is offering you a
manager role for for 30 grand year you
go to another Starbucks that Starbucks
is offering you 40 Grand a year for the
same job which one you're gonna pick nah
I get it but I'm just saying from a
guy's point of view
just in this day and age I just feel
like girls don't really put in that
effort girls don't really show that
appreciation they just want want seemed
like a a girl um not long ago where
she's she's messaged me on Instagram
like oh like blah blah blah spoke a few
um spoke a little bit through Instagram
and she sat around it oh yeah she's been
I'm like oh what are you doing this week
she's telling me Oh so where you taking
me
but you've messaged me what do you mean
where am I taking you like I don't you
know I mean instead of thinking instead
of her saying oh like this week I'm free
if you're free I will take you somewhere
else let me cook you dinner
something like that that's more
appreciation that's what makes the group
I've had like I've been fairly
successful on the old internet and
they've been dating websites not once as
a girl said let me come over and cook
you then the onus is on demand and I've
got no problem with that necessarily
because I'm old school and I don't mind
but that would blow my [__] mind if a
woman said that I'd be like wow maybe
she is
all you girls cook yeah yeah African
foods okay what's your specialty cheese
on toast
women women need to come with the wifey
skills man you know I mean as as a what
a guy coming from a Caribbean household
and everything my mum sort of taught me
to be independent so I can cook my own
food I can yeah you know generally do
skills which are associated with women
like
sewing I can sew you know what I mean
that type of stuff so when um a woman
comes to the table she needs to be able
to offer me if she wants the eye the
idea of
um being in a relationship to come into
fruition she needs to be able to offer a
lot of wifey skills stuff which
generally I know
chime in on this because I think women
don't realize like they're looking for
this big moment to show their skills if
you meet a guy and you really like him
the the thing that will trick him more
than anything else is one day he
realizes [__] my my life is way better
with her and she does this for me she
does that for me like I haven't asked
her to do any of these things she's just
trying to make me make my life better
yeah
and this whole uh mentality that we've
got these days with this exchange of
what can you do for me and men are just
as bad I'm not saying that we're not but
like when women do that you cut yourself
like okay yeah but you don't have to say
you just have to show here
we were saying we both need to build
each other I mean you know what I
noticed so it's like the women that
because I always hear this on the shows
where it's like oh I gave him everything
or I did all this for him and I realized
the girls that say this they're actually
spiteful and they keep score because the
most giving women I know they don't keep
sure and they never talk about what they
did for a guy and so that's what I
realized it's like it's actually a red
flag when she's like oh I did all this
because she views herself as the victim
and like she did nothing wrong it was
all him yeah my experience when women
like women be like detectives they start
digging up old [__] like they did they
do two years ago that you've forgotten
about and and that I think that that's a
really bad a pint scoring like when
you're in an argument and you start
going back and forward and it's like
well you did this no you did that and
what started I'm never getting a sorry
so [__] it
I personally feel like when women are
really upset with men like you guys uh
you you want to vent and you want to
like take that out on this and I
understand that but you're not we're not
solving anything yeah but that's why I
think like women having women friends
that actually want you to win is so
important like they have to be married
they can't be single and they have to be
happily married because it's like we
don't we can't dump all our problems on
the guys they don't want to hear about
it that's why I was saying earlier I
don't think men and women are like
supposed to be best friends yeah it
makes sense but wouldn't it be beautiful
if they were exactly I mean
I think I think that's what like
society's been pushing to be honest and
I don't think it's working like you know
like marriage now people are closer to
best friends than they were 100 years
ago and marriage doesn't work now that's
true yeah I think you should be able to
yeah enjoy yourself together it doesn't
work for so many of the more profound
reasons the likes of social media the
likes of promiscuity yeah I think
marriage not working is women's fault
wow yeah you are amazing you're like a
breakfast yeah I've never had a woman
confess no so I hope you are because
look at the numbers okay look at the
numbers if you look at okay no fault
divorce got initiated in the 90s and
what did women do they left eighty
percent of the time women are leaving
and when men leave it like the number
one reasons it's like abuse Infidel it's
it's not that they're more serious where
women are it's like financial and one
other thing I'm butchering them but the
last time I checked that's what they
were and so it's like women like the
average age or the average length of a
first marriage is eight years it's not
marriage anymore marriage is not
marriage today because you change the
whole institution by letting people be
divorced because marriage is supposed to
be for better
forever and so when women got the chance
to leave they did yeah because women
don't need men financially as much
correct that's one of the main problems
is now women are out here earning as
much if not more than men
like well what do I really needing for
yeah and women would rather be alone
than be with a guy that's that she views
as equal or less right wow and and
that's what you see because that's the
general Trend since women started
entering the workforce in the 20s yeah
society's [__] when women list their
things that they're looking for in a
mine it'll be taller than me makes more
money than me bigger stronger than me
more intelligent than me like they want
a superior yeah in a lot of ways and and
most most women won't ever settle if
they don't get like and that's the
partially that social media came in and
said oh you should all and Disney you
should all have Prince Charming he
should sweep you off your feet he should
do all of that
yeah Disney never said what did
Cinderella bring to the team exactly
again we've been conditioned we've seen
this from Young so automatically we're
like oh that's what I want is
conditioning we've all been conditioned
to think that's the norm the whole thing
about bringing stuff to the table
like I'm I'm just confused by it because
when our parents got together they came
from nothing and came together and made
something so
generation is the first generation that
got divorced like like our parents
aren't the ones we should be taking
advice from it's more of our
grandparents or our great-grands yeah
and the thing is and the thing is too
like that women did bring they were more
in shape they were they were more they
were younger they were better looking
like the question though like those
people they did not have Instagram so
they didn't sign up you don't understand
the lay of the land
[__] Baker there was nothing wrong
yeah you ain't got a [__] clue that
you could potentially have a guy like
this rich guy [__] sliding in your
DMs you want none the wiser so you want
again exactly women yeah like a catalog
of men that they could never have yeah
and made them think they could and and
also like our grandmothers and our
great-grandmothers like they could cook
things from scratch like I see girls on
Instagram like sometimes I follow y'all
after the show but I'll see them out to
eat like every day but I've never seen
them cook anything on their store
that now that they you have to agree if
you don't want to be cheated on you must
believe that you're doing every single
thing correctly but um I mean the
important thing I'm not on the platforms
like that like I said I like to be you
should be you might find your prince
charming Oh no you're going pretty sure
if you're watching this bro I love you I
see you but no I mean I'm I'm content
I'm secure I'm okay in that side of
things but I mean with me I've never I
don't know maybe because of when I I was
growing up there wasn't anything called
like
the internet I remember when the
internet came in and
I feel that you know I just don't yes I
love cooking and I love baking and I
love doing all of those things but I
just don't put myself out there like
that
no no yeah exactly and I don't knock
anybody who has the confidence to go out
and do that me personally I just
couldn't put everything out there like
that me personally but like sorry go no
no sorry go ahead go oh so yeah so you
know back to the point that I was trying
to make like it's just we're in a
different time now where we are under
pressure we are you know like our great
grandmothers and great-grandfathers yeah
they were married until like they
parties man and like I come from a stock
where that was instilled in me where
that's what I saw and they were still
madly in love with each other and yes
they may disagree but they still came
together and they you know like you said
there's a time where it could have just
been a baker she could have just been a
you know a stream wrist and you know but
they built something right but this has
been this is It's genuinely because of
where like do you guys agree that in
general sex comes before relationships
nowadays yeah in general now yeah got
some Capers
sometimes hex sex happen just if you're
doing something yeah but women are in
control of who they sleep with like
women are in control of that so if
relationships are failing like and
women's are the ones leaving
relationships so it's unfortunate
because when we got all the power we
abused it let me tell you the music in
the wrong way do you think it's fair for
women to expect monogamy if they have
children from a previous guy
ah I mean nothing you should expect to
monogamy if the conversation hasn't been
had otherwise you know what I mean just
generally exactly yeah um it's more
likely if you I feel like if you've got
children from a previous relationship
um I think it's probably more likely
that you're going to get cheated on
um because you're going to know that
that person probably has less option to
just walk away after that it's more it's
more likely that they will try and work
out if they've already got children from
a past relationship they don't
necessarily want to lose that person
that have been in a relationship with
you know what I mean so um
yeah I I think that as long as as long
as there's honesty you know anything's
possible but without that then you know
and don't ever undermine the power and
influence of a stepfather or a
stepmother yeah I came from a single
parent family who had shout out my mum
my Dad ran away and this man came into
my life and he's the biggest blessing
that's ever happened to me so like
honestly don't I know this is a random
spur sorry it's just emotion speaking
it's the most important thing it's the
only thing that could potentially
eclipse the Heartbreak of not knowing
your real father or your real mom yeah
if someone's strong enough manly enough
or Willy enough to come in I take that
role it doesn't fill the void it
permanently but it does help it helps
heal the hurt so much and I put that
male energy as well yeah you probably
need it yeah but the issue is it's just
a bad deal for guys to be honest to date
a single mother but you say that though
yeah I could pull my stepdad right now
and I'll tell you for a fact I know I'm
not talking about it he hit the jackpot
right I'm not I'm not talking about you
and I'm talking about in general
hypocrite on that because I was raised
by a single mother
my mother me as an angel but I wouldn't
want to go with a woman who already has
a child and that's just no disrespect
it's just like yeah for me that makes
sense for me I'm I I just wouldn't want
to do that because it's a lot to take
from and there's another man in the
situation I don't want to have to deal
with that but at the same time I'm a
single mom yeah I'm a a mom and in the
same time when you want to meet me you
already know that I have a child and
obviously she will be my number one
priority doesn't matter no matter what
even myself I'm gonna put myself last
and that's why it's it's kind about
respect for me it's because I'm like
I can't yeah you know I can't make a
mistake with a woman who's got a child
yeah there's that football Jerry Maguire
movie where it's like you don't want to
shop the putty like you don't you don't
mess around with a woman who's got a
child already you have to treat her with
a lot of respect it's a it's a different
thing it's a more dangerous situation
because people get hurt more well and
you're supposed to pick up and you're
supposed to put disagree you're supposed
to say what do you disagree with yeah I
mean yeah you have to put uh respect and
all that but
because I'm a single mom doesn't mean
I'm a very weak person I'm more stronger
than ever
no what I mean is because there's a
child involved I treated ex more
seriously than if it's just me and a
girl and if our feelings get hurt that's
the that's one thing when there's a
child involved that's a whole bigger
situation and that's why I wouldn't yeah
I agree I would be more oh is this what
I want to do but at the same time if you
can be straightforward and at the point
and honest and to have an open
conversation with me obviously we can
agree
and if things are not working out that's
completely fine I'm not going to get
upset I'm not going to be depressed
because you don't that's your and look
that's you but like I don't know every
girls are stronger yeah of course yeah
yeah yeah that's that's good I'm talking
just about myself well but there's a
couple issues because one if they raise
um in the UK If you raise someone else's
kid you have no rights to that kid so
it's like you could bond with the kid
for 10 years and you have no rights to
it dude if you've got your own kid yeah
right but at least at least that like
your genes are passed on but like if you
think of it from like a genetic point of
view there's no reason for a guy to date
a single mom yeah but it's never about
the legalities of genetics it's about
how you feel it it's about the
impression you leave on another fellow
human being yeah I've just told you I've
spoken about a stepfather more fondly
than I did about my own father that is
that that that's worth something surely
and I know we're not making it about me
but God Jesus Christ man someone out
there must understand that it's a
beautiful thing to raise a child that's
not yours and I think that sounds nice
again like it sounds really nice but you
know if you had a son you wouldn't
encourage if you had no kids you're not
going to encourage him to date a single
mom if I met a woman who was beautiful
and gave me everything that I wanted but
just so happened to have a child you
think I'm going to say no because you I
think you should I think that's not very
good I think but I wouldn't be the
person I am today if my stepfather and
again I think that's like great for you
and I think you you ended up in a good
situation but I think nowadays it's like
you have so much to risk going into
relationships as a guy like you have so
much to like you don't you might not
even understand it I just know because
I'm doing this documentary in the court
system so and it's like you you could
spend five years of your time attention
and resources and she can leave on a
dime I mean they're already leaving the
father of their kids yeah like what
happened to me before I mean the the one
of the last relationships I was in
um with the mother of one of my children
um
she already had three children when I
when I first met her we've got a child
together but she already had three
children three beautiful children
um we were in a relationship for you
know five years
um in that time I became somewhat the
these children's real father you know I
mean I'm there with them every day I'm
doing the school runs picking them up
parents evenings you know doctor's
appointments all those kinds of things
and then um once our relationship had
finished
I no longer had any rights for those
children you know I mean I built up this
beautiful relationship I look at them no
different from my own biological
children you know what I mean they were
my children they asked even till this
day they still are my children
was there that involved or was it that
like hoping or was he all right he's
about well he's not about about that you
know what I mean and and
even the way that he would raise the
children would be slightly different
from the way that I would raise children
you know I mean so we have our
differences in that and it everyone is
different anyway that's the other like
that's the other issue I've heard is
like does she respect your authority
over the kids because they're not your
kids well it depends how long you've
been together because obviously if
you're in the beginning of your
relationship it's not gonna but if
you're not respecting him in the
beginning how does he know your respect
your future you respecting him but in
the same time you have to build that
trust over time how did you feel bro
just out of curiosity I'm giving back to
those free kids would you see it as some
people insinuating as something that you
wouldn't encourage your next man to go
through or you know what do you regret
it at all I don't regret it I don't
regret I mean I think it's taken a
mental toll on me
um however I don't regret it I feel like
the um the input which I put into those
children's lives you know has been
positive and I think that one day when
they grow up they will really appreciate
it 100 but what have you sacrificed and
that's what I'm saying yeah it's like I
wouldn't even like to have a breakup
with a girl and her keep the dog it
would [__] I love dogs
let alone like me attaching myself to a
child and feeling like I love this kid I
feel like it's mine but it is like
literally nothing to do with me
would you encourage your son to do it
you know I I'm personally I Believe In
Hope and and you know positivity so I
would hope that you know if my son did
go into that situation he would be able
to make the right decisions to make that
relationship last
um and and stick it out for the long run
because as I say you know a child needs
a father exactly if you can be that
positive role um
that's on her to get back with the dad
of her kids like isn't it better if the
actual dad is in in their lives yeah but
yeah of course of course so my question
is if she's leaving though and I'm not
talking about your personal life but if
she's leaving the mother like the father
of her kids which more likely than not
she did yeah of course and it's like
what incentive does she have to stay
with you if she didn't even make it work
with the guy who she had a child because
we don't know we don't know that the dad
that she was with he might have been
abusing her physically he might have
been well and there's a little bit of a
red pill on abuse not as many women that
say there abused were abused and a lot
of people don't know this because of the
way the family court system is you have
to ask if they filed a criminal case and
if the answer is no they may not have
been because the family court you don't
need any evidence to accuse and even um
Pro like sort of prosecute where there's
legal consequences
um a guy of abuse so there's a lot of
girls that go around saying they're
abused and they weren't
I just think it's a good thing to do and
I don't want to lose hope in humanity
that if you were to date a girl who has
a child exclusively makes you a coward
but because of my personal experience
but you have to definitely be scarce
going into that situation with um
knowingly knowing that I mean I would
just say don't do it to be honest you're
supposed to just write them off
I think I think that men deserve to have
standards yeah and if I if I know a guy
and I think he's a good man and he's
worked hard to have like to build a good
career and he has a lot going for him I
would never tell him to risk that by
dating a single mother it's not I don't
have anything personal against single
mothers but if I'm talking to my brother
or someone I love
um no I wouldn't want them to do that
okay because I mean looking back in the
situation how much of myself really went
into raising these children and they're
not actually my children and what did
you get out how much of my time yeah
yeah I haven't got much
you did you referred to them as three
beautiful children you are passionate
about me you care about them
if it is your kid biologically what
makes you think that the woman is going
to stay with you more so than if it's
not your kid if she wants to leave you
she's going to leave you regardless if
it's okay
but what's the best predictor of future
Behavior yes past Behavior so she's done
it before she's likely to do it but we
need to understand why no but you need
to know what's to say
something but something's wrong with her
decision making okay
wait wait wait wait wait something is
wrong okay because I genuinely believe
everything in life is your own goddamn
fault you are the product of your
choices okay so if she is a single
mother she either likes abusive and
toxic men which means you won't live up
because she likes the drama she likes
something about it that's what she picks
or or she leaves when it gets hard but
maybe there's other there's other
situations about if what about if okay
you're saying
okay she's the one that left okay let's
flip it and reverse it he was the one
that left her and then made her a single
mother do you feel that she now because
he decided to walk away from the
responsibility because it got too much
would you feel that it's okay for her to
just be right off because he chose to I
would say she has a poor choice in men
yeah I would say I would say that says
how could you say that how could you
yeah
no I I think he shouldn't leave I think
it's wrong for him to leave but I I know
too much about the court system here
like I know too much a lot of when no a
lot of women keep the keep the kids away
from the fathers
a lot of men grow up thinking their
dad's a deadbeat and he's not and that's
a lot and that's another risk you're
gonna get with the single mom you only
hearing her side of the story so you
don't so you right so you don't know the
full picture so if he's she's saying oh
he abused me he this well now I know
that you're accusing a guy of abuse she
could accuse you of abuse and because
you don't know if she's telling the
truth no I understand so so like these
are just all risk factors that go up so
I think men deserve to have standards I
think men can demand I want an In-Shape
childless woman I think men have every
right to say that and they should
because genuinely I think women wouldn't
leave as much if men stop putting up
with this if women knew if I have two
kids did I don't make this work nobody
is going to want me I think they would
figure it out a lot more
but they always think the grass is
greener on the other side and a lot of
times it's not you know sometimes I have
to disagree but in this instance she's
kind of right no no I get what you're
saying
but I mean like you were saying where
does that leave it's just it's
unfortunate we're just we're a whole
magnitude of individual young kids and
broken women are going to be ostracized
that's right enough whether it's good or
not it's just not enough but it's
sometimes but it's honest no it's it is
honest
but at the same time it hurts me it
breaks my heart it kind of you know it's
it's I don't know like I I totally
received and understood everything that
you just said actually there is a part
of me that I have to say that I can't
wholeheartedly go a hundred percent and
say I agree with that because like you
stated like you know
um your father wasn't there
and another person's stepped in and like
you said it didn't but he's the
exception of the rule and that those men
who are willing to do that they're great
guys you know your stepdad great guy and
he's my role model and I'm certainly not
saying that men who do that are bad guys
I mean but equally as as he found out
it's a risk he said but all this energy
all this money all this time and then
have nothing to show for it and don't
get me wrong yes the memory is in those
kids minds and all of that that's lovely
thing but reality is what did it take
out to him and if I was given advice to
my kid and I think if I was having an
open enormous conversation with none of
these cameras here with my boys we'd all
say ideally it's not the ideal scenario
yeah but to say it's a risk it's almost
so insinuate that it's risk-free further
I would say never do it I would say
don't do it
go for what I would for you and and
being in a relationship and having these
children sort of if I can paint in the
picture you know one of the children was
two years old when I came into her life
you know I mean so she only really saw
me as a father figure the other two
children were a little bit older so they
knew their dad yeah right and I knew him
to be doing father activities and stuff
but when I came in I was like their dad
so from when we broke up and I haven't I
no longer have um
access to them children as much as I did
if I was to get into a love relationship
now if the if the person had children I
wouldn't totally write off but I would
because yeah because of being a random
children I probably wouldn't have much
responsible from your experience I
understand I understand it logically and
practically but what I don't like is
that
um the the reference to risk riskiness
because life life is a risk you marry a
woman down the drain down the drain down
the Iowa and you say yeah I do mate if
you think you are risk-free from her
cheating on you you're crazy okay so
everything's there is okay everything's
a risk but okay you have a daughter
right no like imagine yeah okay are you
gonna tell her to date a guy with a
Criminal past
I think that's that's the best option
yeah but come on well you are gonna
compare a criminal yeah it's just a
single mom no okay I'm gonna just wait
okay wait okay are you gonna tell her to
yeah my daughter yeah no why
because uh if he was a criminal he's
likely to commit a crime on you
potentially okay okay so if she left the
first guy yeah she's what more likely to
what
leave you right I don't agree with that
logic oh it's why but why do you because
it's interesting it happens a lot it's
like the male versus a woman but it's
the same the whole concept it's not
about criminal versus single mom it's
that past actions dictate future actions
that's the whole point yeah but you had
one relationship that's not true do you
know how many passes I know that used to
be gang bangers drug dealers and now
they've given their life to Jesus Christ
and they've changed right your past
doesn't dictate your exceptions
exceptions it's not the rule
it's not it's not the rule most people
don't change overnight and they've done
research on this okay people don't
change all right so let's let's go
around the table here yeah are you the
same man that you were when you were 16
that you were today
are you the same girl that you were when
you were 16 that you are today are you
the same person that you were when you
were 16 and you are today people change
of course that's the evolution of life
that's the beauty of it relying on the
change though what what Pearl is saying
is we've got past evidence of a decision
and that decision could directly impact
the decision that you're about to make
to be in a Unity with that woman
but that's assuming she's at fault for
this
she's using data that she has to to look
at the future it's not saying that Pearl
is definitely right on everyone
categorizing all these women into that
one box not all women and we all know
that because this way if a woman has a
child for a man and that that guy
chooses not to be in the child's life is
that the woman's fault so she's been
written
yes because it's who you picked yeah but
do you every time wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait this is this is the thing
with girls it's like you blame everyone
else for your circumstances you know I
I've been cheated on right and it was my
own fault because I picked him yes okay
yeah
wait wait because taking accountability
means taking accountability for the wait
wait wait Jesus Christ shut up it's like
wait it's like because taking
accountability means that the situation
you're in is your own fault and not
blaming the world for your poor choices
and I'm sorry if you're in the position
of being a single mother you've poorly
chose at some point maybe it was the guy
you wait maybe it was the guy you picked
that was the poor choice maybe it was
how you acted in the relationship that
was the poor choice maybe I don't know
what the poor choice was but but you
can't say I am in the situation I had
nothing to do with it
wait wait please please please this will
answer the question I have a question if
a child is molested by a relative is it
his fault if a child is if a child is
molested okay let me let me answer okay
so this is the thing you always go to an
extreme scenario you no I don't think
the molestation is the child's fault but
I actually I do think there's some
accountability on the parents about who
you let around your kids I do believe
that okay because we just said that we
all buy products and everything that
happens to us is our phone okay okay
fine I'll make an edit I'll make an edit
as an adult as an adult it's not your
fault as the kid if you're born into a
bad situation it's not your fault as a
child but as an adult your circumstances
are your own fault so in relationships
do we not get many heads up do we not
say little things that we like I've said
about when a woman has certain assets
that I'm impressed by but other things
that are major flaws and I ignore them
and later on down the line I realized
that ain't going away I have to actually
address that do we not get
heads-ups way down like earlier on in
the scenario that we could have listened
to but that we don't act on and you know
some people are great at being deceptive
and being conniving enter and then to
place the responsibility and the onus on
the woman
though about like personal advice expert
conniving men who are almost like uh out
uh Robert Robert De Niro level actors
like regular people generally will show
you their flaws if you live with them
like I've said live with a girl for
three months you'll find out who the
[__] she is straight away boom do you
think do you think it's not the guys or
um do you think it's also not a guy's
fault if he repeatedly lets women use
him for his money
[Music]
like when it's in the man you say it's
his fault of course but when it's the
woman you say oh no not the woman's
fault you know why because listen listen
because you're based in your experiences
on data I'm basing it on real life I've
seen what my mom's going through so for
me to sit here and say that I'm going to
encourage another man to not take a a
step I can't do it I can't do it I won't
do it sorry but you always give them one
example she's using I can only go off
what I've lived
with hundreds of women like hundreds and
they all say that which part
um I just don't see how a woman with a
kid is less valuable than a woman
exactly
it even sounds so wrong
okay what what what is value what makes
someone value
how do you define like who's valuable it
depends on what value means to you
that's what I'm saying okay if a product
is worth a lot how do you how do you
determine that it's worth a lot that
there are what
there are multiple people that want to
buy it right so that's so there are good
buyers all right and there's a reason
you use PlayStations are cheap other new
ones just say no that is not my analogy
for women just to be absolutely clear
don't get me on that I mean you can't
you could you you are high mileage you
know what I'm saying like yeah no but
it's so it's like if single mothers have
less buyers and I think it's
disingenuous to say any like to say
anything else that's why we view men who
do that as Heroes because you're like
you're a [__] good guy yeah because
most men wouldn't do that yeah there's a
saying any guy can be a dad but it takes
a real man to be a father
that's why we raise
information
this is another Trend I always notice
like it's always about like the men
they're not real men unless they do
something that benefits women yeah no
I'm serious
so I can't experience it but what I can
say is relating back to the conversation
we had earlier about guys
I'm sorry yeah relating back to the
conversation we had earlier about
um
guys selling women a dream how does a
woman know you know like he saw to this
big dream now she's had kids with
actions and she thinks what if these
actions are aligned
like she's seen his true colors and she
he's not where I I honestly think that
is that I think that that's a story that
women tell and I think it's dishonest
most of the time there are exceptions
all right so please don't say not every
woman like I know I know but I I think
most of the time your brother could have
told you there was a red flag your
father your friends I think there's been
people all along the way that said not a
good idea I've had my sister on the
phone describe a [__] guy to me and
I've been like football yeah stay away
immediately and the women don't listen
and then later play the victim and say
oh he was the worst he did all this
stuff but it's like okay everybody told
you and you didn't listen and now you're
gonna be the victim when really you just
again it's your own fault because you
made that decision
I don't think the majority of the time
men just sell women a dream I think they
don't women don't listen but what if
she's got pregnant with him like really
quick
um okay well then why weren't you on
birth control
not not you but I'm saying to her right
because women there's no excuse for
being a single mother in 2023 when
abortion is legal and there are 40 forms
of birth control I'm sorry
wait wait wait wait wait I'll let you go
I'll let you go but I'm sorry there's
condoms you can require the men that you
sleep with wear condoms oh if that
doesn't work you can get the other thing
in your arm wait wait wait wait wait
wait you can get it wait wait wait Jesus
it's like so first first you can you can
require the man that you sleep with wear
condoms then you can you can do the IUD
birth control the thing in your arm
there's like a million forms of birth
control that you can use then on top of
that there's Plan B in 2023. there's
also abstinence which nobody talks about
is an option nowadays like not having
sex that's all also an option and then
on top of that you you have abortion
that's legal so and then if you don't
want to do that there's adoption
so and the men get no choices in this so
when you have sex with and you also can
track when you're ovulating there's a
natural way to do it you only can
ovulate like three to five days a month
so when it's like it just happened it's
like you were being irresponsible on
some level because you know when you're
ovulating that when when a man and a
woman have sex the woman is the only one
that has all of the information
what three days yeah it's only like
three to five days roughly yeah yeah you
can you can track when you're ovulating
when you're fertile so she knows us yeah
so when a man and a woman have sex
there's only one person in this scenario
that has all the information because the
woman knows if she's on birth control
the woman knows if she's ovulating the
woman knows if she's going to take the
plan B and the woman knows if she'll get
an abortion the man only knows what she
tells him which could be a lie and and
and she knows if he's wearing a condom
or not and I just don't believe the
whole oh I didn't know he took it what
but people wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait thank you okay
and so the man the man he doesn't have
all the information the woman does so
therefore the woman has more
responsibility because she has more
power in that situation I'm going to let
you go what have he's changed now okay
wait I'm gonna let her go first because
no I was gonna say like with the whole
contraception my thing is a woman can
only get pregnant once a year a man can
go forth and multiply it different
occasions in a year so why is it for a
woman to be on contraception why I'm
just saying in general why are women's
the ones taking contraception why can't
it be the man that's unconscious
but it's a woman's choice at the end of
the day and that what what Paul's trying
to explain as well like obviously you
look could be on contraception but it's
your choice to have a child with someone
that you don't fully believe that but in
the same time you're in a wrong wrong
relationship right and you decided to
have a kid together but the things are
not working out after the baby but then
my question is why don't you get married
first
how does that change anything
but if you are married and that is the
situation and the person still decides
to leave you do you do you have a
college degree you have a college do you
have a college degree yes okay so if you
get married there's a 10 chance he'll
leave there's a 90 chance you'll leave
so let like why don't we talk about the
women first before we talk about wait
say that statistics if you're a woman
and you have a college degree there's a
90 if you get divorced there's a 90
chance you'll leave only a 10 chance
he'll leave the other way around is if
it's just a normal marriage there's only
a 20 chance the male leaves and the
leading reasons that they leave it's
abuse it's like uh infidelity and
something there and it's like being on
draw it's really crazy because again
because again the contract is so bad for
men when they leave they're only leaving
when it's extreme
hold on but what happens I have taken
all precautions and I have made sure
that I'm safe and it is the universe the
galactic God however you want to make it
if it was meant to be for me to carry
and bring forth that seed what then
I've protected myself giving you the
condom I'm on birth control but I'm
still full pregnant and then he still
decides to leave oh my God what happens
then I think that you're a Capper then
because I just
let me answer the question then my gosh
it's like okay if you're gonna tell me
you're gonna tell me all right so you
don't believe in abortion I'm also
pro-life so we're on the same time I'm
not okay wait that was great that
somebody else said Okay okay so so if
you're pro-choice then then you have
zero excuse because you believe in
abortion but let's say you don't I just
have a hard time believing that you took
all the precautions you tracked your
cycle and said I'm not ovulating today
so I can have sex oh I'm gonna make sure
he wore a condom and I'm gonna make sure
I have an IUD with a 99.5
rate of success I just don't believe it
okay so it could never happen though we
could okay it could be an extreme
exception sure okay
I know a few people just got pregnant
after the morning yeah well because they
did nothing and then took the pill after
it's like why didn't you do it that's
like a Hail Mary do we think the strip
oh that uh Drake got pregnant just took
all the precautions she's beautiful
um but you know what I mean if you see
this drop me a message
when Drake's baby mama got pregnant like
and she was a video dancer and all of
that like she knew find about what she
was doing I bet you if we tracked the
data of accidental pregnancies with men
who have a higher income the graph goes
like that yeah whereas bums who work in
the dead end jobs I bet you there's very
little accidental pregnancy I just don't
believe there's any accidental pregnancy
in 2023 I don't believe it yeah I don't
there's too many there's too many
options especially with abortion y'all
can get abortion up to six months for
free here seriously yeah and you know
it's crazy that babies have lived before
abortion is legal
so like babies have survived like you
guys haven't legal past when like
children have survived which is kind of
crazy but but yeah but most people most
women are pro-choice so it's like I'm
pro-life I wouldn't do that but most
women would so when abortion's legal
women have 100 control of who's born men
have zero control over that women of 100
control if they put a guy in child
support men have zero control over that
women have a hundred percent control
over putting a guy on alimony men have
zero control women women have um
alimony's marriage
um women have a hundred percent control
over if
acute they could accuse a guy of abuse
and take him to family court and
restrict him from seeing his kids for
like two years until they get to court
with no evidence like because she can
literally make one call and do that bro
we've got [__] up bro that's what I'm
saying you that's what that's what I was
talking about earlier when I said you
don't understand the risks that come
that's why when girls say that this is
the thing like you cannot no no offense
to you but when girls say they were
abused you have to ask them did you file
a criminal report because in a criminal
court it actually is based off of
evidence where family court it's not and
a lot of girls will cap and I've even
seen like they've shown me Tech like
text messages from the girl like
plotting to accuse him of abuse I
believe that like they they literally
planted some vicious I guess I guess I
would disconnect then earlier was I was
just speaking from my heart but when you
break it down like that my Infamous
salesman used to say men like women lie
numbers don't lie so if the statistics
are speaking you make a lot of money
just just let's say you got married ish
you got you got a divorce and that that
girl who you got divorced from you're
now paying for all of her coffee by the
way right right so so she decides I'm a
[__] with this guy I'm gonna ring my
lawyer every day for 31 days solid and
at the end of that 31 days that bill is
going to you just because she decided to
[__] with you and you know what you can
do about it nothing and the other crazy
thing like because you were talking
about that you would date a girl that
does only fans or like any of the sexual
stuff but if a girl if a girl slept with
more than like five to seven guys her
ability to bond with men goes down
significantly so it's like if she's a
virgin on her wedding night she has it
depends on the study but like a 60 to 85
chance of a happy marriage it's more
than five it goes down to 20 to 25
percent I've seen it firsthand I've seen
it firsthand yeah and so it's like
that's that thing why no definitely I've
seen it I physically experience a woman
sleeps over with loads of men if a guy
if a girl like her ability to bond with
men switch is at about like five to
seven men where it goes down like so if
you were a virgin on your wedding night
you have a 60 to like 80 chance of being
happily married in 10 years but after
you sleep with around five to seven
seven men it goes down to like 20 to 25
percent okay and so it's like if a guy
you've done it already the novelty's
well enough you've experienced it yeah
yeah it makes sense but it's true it's
fixed and it's the same thing women
release a hormone when they have a kid
with someone else so it's like a guy
that's in your position where you've
done well financially it's like that's
why I'm a bit of a conundrum no I kind
of no I kind of look at you like you're
crazy because I'm like you have so much
to lose and you're going into it and
you're not taking it into account any of
the risk factors like the high body
count you're okay with the single mother
you're okay with then I'm like I'm just
a good guy man but there's also a reason
why I'm single I don't believe in
marriage and I don't want kids so oh you
don't want kids no you don't believe in
marriage I don't know I believe well if
my mom's watches I believe in marriage I
think it's the right thing to do but I
just don't want it and I'm not gonna do
it no because of all the aforementioned
reasons it's too much of a risk factor
you know too much to lose it's crazy
because you were Mr monogamy the whole
show yeah I am Mr monogamous and it
doesn't mean that you you can't be
monogamous outside of me such a man what
I say doesn't mean what I'm actually
going to do yeah exactly
exactly exactly
it's great just for other people yeah
obviously you said earlier on obviously
about
um obviously with what you do the only
fancy thing or whatever and you're
saying you're making all this money
which I bro I congratulate bro I
appreciate it but it's a thing where
obviously you said that
with the woman think you don't really
wanna lady
what'd you mean in terms of like you
said that oh I do I do in the future
okay in the future but but obviously you
said because you look this good and all
this stuff but obviously when we get to
a certain age and then obviously we're
changing obviously we are gonna want
that and then you're gonna look back and
see obviously I want 20 or 30 years old
so I don't look as good as I did before
then obviously like I'm saying the
standards are gonna go a bit more and
then you're not going to settle down
with what you wanted like what you
initially want like now but I'll tell
you what for what I what what for what
I'm deficient in physically I will
compensate for financially so if you've
ever seen a guy who looks really ugly
but he's got a bagging 10 out of 10 girl
he's got bread in his music so trust me
I will have so much money
will be willing to do the Men in Black
situation
you're making your income from what
you're doing now yeah from the way you
look right now yeah it's not like
obviously no obviously
yeah cool yeah I understand
it's only because you've only mentioned
of course of course
I found another guy on oaf you could
stay doing that until you're like 40s
right I know one guy I know one guy he's
41. um I'm not gonna say his name
because he doesn't yeah but he's doing
really well making 30 40 came up I've
heard girls have like a shorter yeah
yeah yeah there's put it this way
there's a niche for everyone I was
trying to get him to do it before we
went live because I told him everyone
get it out of your head that you need to
have a six-pack and be turned in all of
this no there is a market
and the words in the wise words of an
Irish colleague he said I can get buffer
I can never get taller so I would change
my six-pack for your high any day of the
week so don't worry man that was a [__]
you can do it not get viewed differently
but women do it oh you'd be surprised
you'd be surprised you should see what
my family members say about me I don't
think if I do I don't think I'm
you know
I don't think yeah but let's face it
you're not going to say a guy who says
he doesn't get a thing yes I'm gonna
bring him home to my mum no but you know
what it is though yeah you see that you
can do only fans yeah and I can pretty
much guarantee that you're not going to
end up alone
in your life because girls don't know
I'm just being girls are looking like I
can say to a girl I've had
you know I've slept with 20 girls this
year yeah and to be fair it's not going
to be that much of a bad thing you know
what I mean like a girl will take that
on the chin I've got three baby mothers
you know wow yeah three three for free
how many kids have you got yeah three
kids
yeah
and I'll tell a girl down and she'll be
like I'll be your fourth it's not a
problem you know what I mean
for women sorry if a woman say to me
like oh I've got three baby Barbers I'm
like okay you know what I mean the point
the Pearl makes I think is that on
average the data means that the cream
rise at the top like the people in the
best circumstances get the best partners
and as much as we want to like see a lot
of nice things around here that's just
reality isn't it it is yeah
so what's the moral of the story it's
about cheating
no look it I I my moral of the stories
the grass isn't always greedy or on the
other side and if he cheats on you you
can leave but that doesn't mean you'll
find someone else who won't cheat who
won't cheat and maybe if you got a kid
you should figure it out because it's
about their feelings first better the
devil you know my mom used to say yeah
so you're saying better off being with
someone who can provide rather than
being with a bum
though
I don't want no scrub
copyright
also you know
well about a scrap yeah I would say if
you were to pick one a provider or a guy
that's a bum I would pick the
responsible guy I think that's so if you
have the mentality in like every man
cheats if you have that mentality or at
least I mean I think people should go
for like similar value similar family
backgrounds first
um to be honest like I think there's
certain like like depending on your
culture like there's certain like it's
easier when you guys have a similar like
not even a bum like an average guy for
example I think it depends what you want
I feel like women want competency as
well like what they want a man who they
know they can rely on just do what he's
actually says he's gonna [__] do when
I'm meeting women in the day in scene
and a lot of them have this like they're
very disappointed with men out there
right now like we're letting it down
apparently
um so I do feel like just like it's not
all about income it's also just about
things yeah well it's also like
men are motivated by women and it's like
when the quality of the women of God has
gone down so much and the contract of
marriage it's like what incentive do men
have like genuinely what incentive do
men have to get married today
[Music]
it's a big risk for America one all of
most of in the UK everyone they say
we're so fat in America but it's like 65
percent of women here are overweight
serious yeah yeah in America is scary in
America it's like seven no we have more
extreme obese
it's like what's the average body count
of a 31 year old which is when you're
getting married some are coming in with
kids it's like what incentive do men
have to get married I feel like it's
only for women and nothing as a
bargaining trip for a man it's like okay
I'm gonna do this for you I want these
things covered yeah and it used to be
that they can't leave like they get the
Loyalty right it's okay you know maybe
she's a bet whatever but I get she can't
leave but now it's no fault divorce you
can go that's why I say marriage in 2023
it's not marriage anymore it's it's
something else because marriage is for
better for worse in sickness and health
for richer for poor it's like you do
this you cannot leave no matter sheets I
don't care like whatever it is you
cannot leave but women like we don't
have that mindset anymore it's gone
it's crazy man wow so maybe that's why I
don't believe in marriage then yeah I
feel a little bit about it now you've
broken it down I feel like I'm in a
therapy session
I've understood why I think the way I
think you know the reason there's a
reason why you say you're not going to
get married because you're smart yeah
yeah imagine imagine a lady into your
life now you know that's so scared you
know if I've worked all of this and been
humiliated publicly can you imagine
someone to take 50 percent
it doesn't have to be like that
it doesn't matter
sometimes with marriage like you know
like Pearl said it back in the day it
was more about being together until
we're both six feet under and now I look
at to me some people look at marriage
now as a business
investment and Arrangements women do
yeah I can't see a man doing that no oh
no best believe there are some no there
are some Bros out there
less than six percent of couples the
woman's The Breadwinner so no not really
no there is a few of them but I'm not
really do you get what I'm saying I must
be stupid because I still believe in
marriage I still think it's no I believe
I like the idea of being family and we
have to see in my state yeah our
children I like all of that yeah it
sounds good getting [__] in court
later I know yeah it's worse and
obviously that's never the plan and
ideally you're not going to be in that
situation but the fact it's impossible
it is something now for for a man to do
this
and the other problem is there's no such
thing as a good woman it used to trigger
me because because the guys would say oh
the women are [__] nowadays and I'm
like well I'm not that but when you
think about it women 100 years ago only
15 had sex before they were married only
even if they lied let's just say and it
was double that's still two out of three
were virgins on their wedding night so
it's like buy that by that skill we are
and then the other thing is like they
would say well I want to grow that
believes in marriage like like they
would say oh there's no women that have
loyal now I would get offended but it's
like social media like we are so much
more susceptible to like brainwashing
from social media than men are and
there's so many girls that get on their
phones and they think that there's a
better thing coming so there's no good
woman because every girl can have social
media and a guy can come in and swoop at
any time yeah and so and so that's the
problem is like so what do we do just we
just all be single and give up on
Humanity
there's a study you know men are walking
away that's the problem there's a study
that said it's either 40 or 60 percent
of men don't have no interest in being
in a relationship with women I think see
that's where that's where I'm at bro and
and
it's a fair criticism like I honestly
think it's on the either met well I
think women shouldn't vote I think that
would save a lot of problems that's a
whole different that's a whole different
Rabbit Hole I'm not having a
conversation with one of my friends and
you know um I was saying that
if women were born without vaginas yeah
would we even talk to many females I
don't know if I'd be friends with
females if they didn't have a bit of
vagina
it sounds very very very cautious you're
in dangerous territory here
you don't have to take this journey
alone right so if women did not have
vaginas yeah I don't know if I'd be
friends or talk to a lot well every man
watching this as well you know it's just
to be honest
there are some guys there's a whole
group on YouTube that they they don't
even want to talk to women because they
don't want to be me tuned by a girl
like me too because a girl can say oh
he's creepy oh he's a weirdo okay
there's guys that get in trouble at work
for like like girls basically me too and
him or basically saying oh he did this
like there's literally anytime a man
interacts with a woman there's a risk
there's there's something beautiful
ramification and it's not that it's
gonna happen to everyone but the point
is like we have so much power that we
can in fact 100 I'll give you an example
oh my God I was in the gym right my
local gym and um so this is so weird so
it's weird all right it's going into my
Tick Tock and seeing me on my Tick Tock
live then going for my Tick Tock live
checked the the LinkedIn tree went to my
Instagram saw my Instagram story saw
that I posted a video topless
in a secured place at the gym no one was
there just you know as you do as an
influencer and made a report and a
complaint against me
mate oh my God I thought I was in a
courtroom the way they tackled me and
they said to conclude she's feeling
intimidated
wait hold on a minute wait wait hold on
a minute you're intimidated because you
went on my social media flicked free
from Tick Tock went on to Instagram from
Instagram went over to my stories then
checked and you're intimate I should I
should be intimidated by your stalkerish
Tendencies but you best believe I'm on
my last warning what I'm not even
allowed to look at this girl if I as
much make her feel intimidated one more
time I'm out of there so 100 she's right
women hold way too much power yeah and
you know what I know you're talking
about all of those statistics about
women control birth women control
because
no but this is this is why I think it's
so important that men know this stuff
because otherwise it's like a guy like
you you're walking and I mean you kind
of knew but but you know maybe a younger
guys walking in la la land he has no
idea and he just gets [__] by the
courts yeah I know that's true yeah but
in the same time I know someone yeah uh
who signed a contract if they will ever
get divorced she won't get nothing bring
up so so prenups do it so okay I could I
could tell you that so prenups do help
and from what I understand if they're
done correctly they can be really
effective and I I spoke to a 20-year
divorce attorney about this and he he
does this guy said he believes in
prenups right however the issue is
children he said this this guy did
divorces for 20 years he said I'm not
afraid of marriage but what I am afraid
of is kids because when she has the kids
they're not yours they're hers
and it's like I think 80 80 to 90
percent of divorces um no 80 I think
it's 80 of divorces the the man is on
child some form is child support every
guy I know who's been divorced the
minute and he says a word wrong the
first thing he hears is you're not
saying you're [__] kid yeah thirsting
every everyone I will never say that
I've got a good mate of mine who just so
happens to be in this room outside the
parameters of the cameras and I've seen
firsthand very very good guy very hard
working very studious very humble very
loyal like he's everything I've claimed
to be but it literally is
um and yeah she screwed him over dirty
horribly so when you're saying that you
would never do that okay but it's not
personal to you because I've seen
firsthand that there are vindicative
vicious
but this is
worthy power
we have their children power yeah
I'm letting go now and then we're living
in a woman's world
this is why I don't think women should
vote though and I'll tell you why
because when women got power we abused
it we didn't have we didn't have power
before like it was like the 20s or the
30s we got the right to vote this is why
I don't think we should because what
happened when we did we abused it like
we have we have I think we live in a
like a matriarchy basically I think we
have a system that systematically
oppresses men and no one cares and you
know what like I don't necessarily agree
with what you're saying that to be
honest because if any woman sees that
I've agreed with that I'm getting masked
but the reality in All Seasons women now
wear the Panzer relationship that
because of all of these little things
they're all factors in like I know grown
men who were like double barreling their
last names and taking women's last names
now and their kids have the woman's name
and their name like and they're not the
same like he used to yeah the old days
are just things because how could it not
be like men have like women have to wear
the pants because if me and you were in
a contract right and if I win everything
by walking away you lose everything by
walking away you're always gonna try to
make me happy babe it's okay you're all
right you're gonna be at my mercy and my
will and I think that's like that's the
issue is these laws change the way that
men and women literally interact and
it's funny I've been learning more about
this like a lot of
a lot of the the laws that we have in
the books and like feminism's Roots is
actually demonic like it's from a tribe
in India where freaking they would
sacrifice men to the like a female
goddess yeah yeah it's it's a whole
rabbits
that's why you have all the girls they
come in with like other crystals and
their horoscopes that those are all
literally demons
wait what do you mean I've I've seen it
go with crystals I mean they don't know
they're doing it but they don't know the
roots like they don't know the roots
behind it but yeah it's like a lot of
the [__] that's in I just did an
interview with this girl I was red
pilled even further but yeah like a lot
of the stuff that they they use with
feminism is literally demonic like the
crystals the horoscope and and that's
why women call each other's Queens
because she was a queen that they're
sacrificing men to oh okay
and they run everything and that's how
women control so Society because even
though it's men in power women are 55
percent of Voters so we control the vote
and so men the voters have to Pander to
that's why the laws don't change because
they have to Pander to the women in
order to get the votes
and what group that's in power will ever
give it up never that he's had an
epiphany
today and the thing is the crazy thing
is in the 20s women didn't even want the
right to vote like 94 94 of women said
they didn't want to vote and it was
because and I I read the writings back
then because they said this is the
breakdown of the family
starting from now like there like it was
supposed to be when you got married two
became one and you submitted to your
husband's Authority it was biblical
right right and so now we're in a
society where it's like men have all the
responsibility they pay most of the
taxes they're the ones that go to war if
[__] goes south but we have all the
power and that what is that that's
slavery basically
[Music]
but not the same please don't please
don't not the same thing not the same
thing but yeah no idea what you mean
what you mean wow it's definitely like
slavery
[Music]
double down on that
that's mad
um yeah can I just Intrigue just out of
curiously where did you get these views
I've never met a woman who thinks like
you ever in my life
um where did I get these views um well I
didn't always think this way but it was
kind of just going down a rabbit hole
I've always been more conservative so
I'm very like Pro I've always been
pro-life I've always been like low taxes
because my dad's really conservative but
like the right to vote really just came
from going down the rabbit hole I wanted
I heard that women didn't want the right
to vote so I was like why because that
to me that was so weird and I started
reading the writings of the the women at
the time that said no I don't want to
vote so then I kept going down the
rabbit hole because they were saying oh
this is what they're gonna try to do
they're gonna try to destroy the family
well that's what they did and then I
realized I was like this is like the
root of all evil yeah literally yeah
wow
like women's Independence and that type
of thing you know I mean and I I you
know although I promote a lot of um [__]
boy activities I do believe in you know
the
um the idea of a two-parent home you
know I do believe in marriage
um I do believe in all of the things
which are supposed to make a genuine
family and and to make it work as well
however I think that there's so many
outfit outside influences there's so
many options it's almost as well it's
almost impossible you know I can have
another you here in a minute because of
those things there we don't have the
same connections as we used to have back
in the day with traditional women you
know what I mean yeah
um shout out to top G he already said
that uh basically if if a woman wants to
walk away you know or to to say that
she's going to walk away in 1960s you
may never see that woman again how was
uh if it was today you know you can have
another a person here in five minutes
yeah you know swipe across on Tinder so
we don't value the same things that
we're used to you know these things are
so loose that we don't have the you know
when it comes to marriage the idea of
marriage is so far away and foreign to
me now yeah that as in I know it won't
work even if I love that woman that
woman loves me yeah there's so many
different
um so many different uh
things which come into play
um being in a relationship so many
different um what's the word variables
yeah different there you go I like it
okay so many different variables which
go into making a successful relationship
that the chances of you
being successful married and then dying
with that person is very married yeah
it's true exactly a three percent chance
you've got the statistics yeah yeah
it's coming yeah you also if you're a
guy you have like a one if you get
divorced it's like
fifteen percent of all marriages like
the woman maliciously like ruins you so
if it's like one out of six divorces
what yeah so that so it's more common
which you know means more likely but
that's just malicious like to the point
like that she's not letting me see your
kid that doesn't include like child
support you know how you're doing a
documentary on these uh divorce issues
I'd love to know the link if there is
one and I'm willing to bet my life that
there is in male suicide and being
divorced yeah guaranteed right because
when women destroy these men financially
God only knows the ruins the no one will
report on that I don't want to report on
the men being but that's the thing no
one really talks about men's mental
health anyway it's very yeah and I think
no well yeah but I think it needs to be
spoken about more because men do suffer
let me let me red pill you one more
thing about mental health okay because
you said earlier like men should cry or
whatever right no I said I cry I didn't
say man should but I'm not a typical man
okay okay but you've heard that right
like mentioned or whatever like in
society whatever is the female way of
doing things is always assumed to be
like right so when they say men should
cry they're saying men should be women
but men don't cry about their problems
they don't say like men should go fight
or like the way that men naturally do
things that scene is bad so in society
like when a guy is fighting on the
school you're another bad kid if he's
being loud and oh he's a bad kid so it's
like we're and then it's mostly taught
by women in schools and psychologists so
they're coming in and telling men to be
women like women yeah well and anything
that deviates from that is not the
reality is if you're a government and
you want to control people the the more
the less masculine yeah
like let's think about all of the
uprisings we've seen in history it came
from men [__] had enough of this [__]
we're taking over and they want you as
subdued as possible yeah that's why
there's more estrogen and water than
ever before yeah but it all stands from
conditioning like yeah when they
condition women to be men too and like
to be fair a lot of them no but look at
the clothes nowadays you're seeing men
wearing more skinny jeans and women in
more baggages though why are men's
clothes becoming so tired
think about it three three out of the
five of us are in pants yeah I know yeah
yeah and it's funny when I walk down the
street I look at that and I think of
like the pictures from like 100 years
ago where the women are all interested
yeah exactly
it's crazy it's actually crazy it's the
society we live in yeah yeah you know
and I think again they want to wear more
like tights clothes and everything just
because they want to show how big they
are actually because they're going gym
that is the new thing that I've noticed
but it's for everyone wait wait wait
wait oh we talk about clothing and gyms
no basically
what we've actually what we were saying
that we have noticed in society that
okay you're going gym you're getting I
don't know how it feels yeah
um you not used per se but other people
would wear like extremely tighter
clothing I don't know if it's to
highlight the breasts and the packs I
don't know I I don't know but I what we
was just saying is that we've noticed
that lately of of lately that some guys
that do go to the gym they're in like
title clothing of course in the 90s if
you look at 90s bodybuilders they're
wearing the baggiest [__] like they're
not they don't show enough if you look
at all of these uh gym Brands there's a
reason why you're going to see someone's
heart beating through their [__]
chest like there's nothing left of the
imagination yeah exactly and I agree
with that yeah it's very spandexy very
feminine oh and that's oh and that and
that is like
there's some tribal thing to that I
don't remember what it was but the the
lady that I interviewed the other day
there's some like demonic tribal thing
like that that's from to like men trying
to be women and women trying to be the
man it's not new like the whole trans
stuff and the same like they they yeah
it's it's like from that same there's
like a couple tribes this came from but
it's from that same tribe
it was like this
I'm talking like 1700s yeah like 1700
1600s if a guy spends six or seven days
in the gym sacrificing abstaining from
going out and drinking and doing what no
more guys do right
he has every right to flaunt his
I think everyone has the right to do
what they want but the point is is it
feminine or masculine flaunting beauty
is a feminine trait so that's Auto
Schwarzenegger you can't get a more
masculine man than that and he appears
on stage naked but this is what you keep
like no offense yeah it's an exception
it's not the rule like when you think of
masculine men in general like Generals
in history
yeah it's like a big fireman yeah
the hairy ones yeah I need to I need to
read super chats and I'll let you guys
go home but we're actually getting
really late sorry guys
I'm hungry I'm sorry but this was fun I
enjoyed red pilling you today thank you
so much I feel like I've learned so
freaking much um okay marriage causes
divorce um thousands of men delete
themselves during divorce millions of
guys consider deletion during divorce
marriage is like giving your wife a
shotgun that's actually a good analogy
in a way uh marriage causes divorce Pro
was nailing it marriage and divorce
creates a huge power imbalance husbands
can't argue back as the wife can take
the money the house and the kids in
divorce he will lose 70 percent of his
assets Amina it's not the eyes that are
blind but the hearts Islam is the only
answer instead of being confused just
open the Quran you won't lose black
Moses it's amazing how average looking
women look down and average men guys get
your passports amanesh I'm a Muslim girl
I listen to these podcasts on
relationship issues problem solved with
Islam people are lost and not talking
nonsense from mind follow God problems
sis I recommend you look into Islam
you'll be happy um Dolly I was raised by
a stepdad that and two siblings from a
stepmom and Mom I and I call stepdad dad
even even if he wasn't my father my
siblings are my brother and sister
Elevate expectations instead of
expecting the worst amen Doug MPA
um guys guy talks about his great step
dad but he's on only fans apparently he
didn't do a good job as he be proud of
you I bet he isn't guys don't date
single mothers step daddy seasons and is
over forever William Smith is the
pendulum swinging laughter has it begun
to swing to the right with voices like
Pearl and others gaining more traction
AJ this is why women will end up lonely
the worst guy in the group for a long
relationship is the of1 he lies more
than he talks still the woman will eat
it up unbelievable and typical Pearl
look in the documentary where a guy
would pick up women on Tinder but he
would act like a pedo and the women did
not care because he was hot oh my God
I've seen that um no no there's a guy
who was on Tinder and he put that he was
a pedophile on it and the girls didn't
care because he was hot
um H.A they're like yeah come on like
they didn't care
um ha The Oaf guy has the same
philosophy and talks like a woman Willie
Philly every man will fold in the right
scenario it's up to you as a man to
avoid risky situations where you'll take
well you'll take a man's loyalty is
tested when he is everything wife and
kids over [__] is an L
um lacia you think modern women would
appreciate not having to fulfill the
aspect of their duties just like they'll
hire a maid or a chef man get your thing
for you you can relax when you need to
Sanja I'm an average guy but I've been
cheated on many times and I've never
wanted to cheat even when the
opportunity arises I'm perfectly content
with one woman and will give me a chance
even when I know it's not going to last
Logan hey Pearl Aristotle once said
masculine republics give way to feminine
democracies feminine democracies give
ways to Taiwanese I thought of this
after your female vote discussion I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the on a
panel
I'm going to refresh it one more time
and then we can do final thoughts so you
guys can plug your social media or say
anything you want to speak your piece on
please not a monologue thank you
um starting here
social media anything you want to speak
your piece on
yes so what I want to say first is don't
cheat
just be honest with uh with each other
and if things are not working out just
you know don't be together anymore and
yeah that's that's my thoughts and my
Instagram is
d-e-y-a two Wonder underscore and X from
x-ray so yeah see you there
okay hi guys my name is Esther and what
I've taken from this podcast I've
learned a lot from you Pearl like your
views and I feel like
um everyone can agree to disagree on
certain opinions that not everyone's
opinions are right I know everyone's
opinions is wrong we just have to form
like an agreement on that and yeah I've
learned a lot from this and I've had a
good chat with everyone here and my
Instagram is aries10 underscore XO all
my other socials are linked on in my bio
and my YouTube channel is aries.x which
I'll be uploading videos very soon so
please follow and support thank you
um yes it's Mary
um I just want to say I have
um enjoyed the discussion today and
you've kind of given me a different
Insight on certain subjects that I was
unaware of which I do appreciate you
you know expressing that and giving us
that information I have enjoyed the
conversation I've met quite a bunch of
lovely people that I'm I wish you all
the best and whatever platforms use that
go on and unfortunately I don't have any
um socials I'm not on any platform but
watch this space
um first of all thank you for having me
um I really enjoyed the show it was you
know very good and it opened my mind to
new topics which was nice
um something I would take away is be
open and honest
um it's the best way forward and yeah my
socials are at lucia.lidell which is
l-o-u-s-h-a Dot and then you'll find me
[Laughter]
thanks
uh Brian here host of the true Geordie
podcast uh we've got Pearl on on Monday
and night yeah it was a really fun
interview so make sure you guys tune in
yeah I had a lot of fun yeah my first
question is what are you to Pearl and
she was like I don't really how do I
answer that
um so yeah you'll really get to see a
bit more of the personal uh side of
pearl on that one and she really opened
up so credit and credit all the lovely
people here I've thoroughly enjoyed your
conversation thanks for having us on
hi guys um so you can add me on
Instagram the life of jills
t-h-e-l-i-f-o-f or
l-i-f-e-o-f-g-i-o-l-z wow I had one shot
and I messed up God damn okay follow me
there and um let's say listen from the
book my heart thank you so much for
having me here for listening to me for
not kicking me out
um I feel like I learned a multitude of
information I came in thinking that men
were domineer and powerful and in
possession of all the authority and I've
come out realizing we don't so that's a
beautiful kind of U-turn
um all I would say to conclude is listen
guys don't get drawn in and sucked into
a man should be this a woman should be
this that should be this you do what
makes you happy that's all that matters
whether you're black white Indian
Chinese it's irrelevant what other
people's perceptions of what is normal
and is abnormal is up to them live life
on your terms and I guarantee you that's
the quickest way to happiness peace and
total satisfaction God bless thanks yeah
am I supposed to follow that off
yes um you can catch really where I'm
gonna firm underscore talk underscore
LDN on Instagram
um you just catch me on there moaning
about things which um pissed me off
pretty much
um yeah what we've learned today man
um
it is good to be a stepfather if you're
going to be a stepfather out there there
are children who honestly do need uh
male role models out there there's not
enough of them out there so although I
probably won't get into a situation
going forward where there are
stepchildren I still respect all
stepfathers out there go do your thing
um and yeah it's just been beautiful
being here today and seeing everyone's
point of views it's been lovely meeting
you po I'm a big fan so yeah crack on we
do yeah
I just want to thank Paul for having me
on that show really appreciate it I met
some beautiful guys today it's been
amazing but um like I say um if you're
in a sad situationship or relationship
and you're not happy and you see the red
flags I would definitely say just pack
your bags move on don't prolong things
it just gets worse but yeah guys I want
to say thank you again and admin on the
socials I go by the name Superstar
creeper Superstar c-r-e-e-p-a Instagram
Snapchat thank you Paul again and thank
you guys
thank you guys all for coming I know
this was a late show so I really
appreciate you guys sticking it out
um a couple announcements before we end
the show um I'll guys sign up for our
Google form we're going to be doing
meetups in the U.S and the UK and I
think we're gonna bring back some people
from the show um to do like music stuff
at the Meetup we're gonna do in the UK
so make sure you guys sign up for that
the link to that should be in the
description blessing can you make sure
it is if it's not
um also guys make sure you subscribe to
our two clips channels just pearly clips
and pearl daily um sign up for our
fourth membership tier to get a
one-on-one call with me once a month
follow my Instagram just pearly things
one and you can send me um any thing
that we should do a show on or any um
things you want me to react to and we
also have a video premiering right after
this where I react to a mgtow video so
make sure you go subscribe to that like
the video on your way out and we'll talk
to you next time
[Music]
would you be willing and accepting if a
strong man came into your life and
helped build you into a wife what I'm
saying is if he came into your life
would you be accepting of him building
you into the wife that he wanted 20 30
years ago this is how the world
functions this is how the whole world
functioned the things I say that somehow
people believe are controversial are
exactly the way the world functioned in
like the 90s the 80s the 70s all of the
entire period of human history men had a
role of masculinity women had a role of
femininity we worked as a team you know
we have a society that panders to one
gender so much of course it's easy to
accept your your participation trophy
for being a queen this is why women need
to be very careful who they keep around
because a lot of times you're in
competition with each other and misery
loves company whenever a woman now on
social media when they see like a famous
woman in a happy relationship you see
them all the time trying to bring them
down trying to catch him cheating they
want to be at the same level because
it's jealousy misery loves company and
so a lot of the friendships that women
have they all unproductive whatsoever a
lot of them are feeding garbage when you
get in a breakup when you have problems
with your boyfriend and you go talk to
your girlfriends what do they say leave
him leave him right now let's go to the
club they don't actually promote
anything positive they just want to
bring you back down to degeneracy I know
my value people are villainize me and I
have villainized myself because it's
like well instead of fighting against it
and I don't know trying to convince
people I'm actually a good-hearted
person it's easier to just be the
villain no absolutely not money the love
of money is the root of all evil and so
a lot of women are selling their bodies
and their souls you have to go to sleep
at night a woman can have equal respect
to a man if she is very good at being a
woman and a man gets respect for being
very good at being a man when a woman
decides she wants to act like a man or a
man wants to act like a woman that's
where all gets [__] up and I hate that
for you because you're a pretty girl
that's really smart and I hate that
you're saying these things because you
could probably be a hell of a good wife
and a good mother you're not a stupid
woman I think you're misled you're
you're half naked therefore I like that
it is just so crazy and it's so
backwards that even dudes like that like
I I used to have guy friends in my life
that would feel like empowered if their
girlfriend wanted to go out and be like
half naked in the club who on the panel
wants to be married
um yeah
panel feels like they were raised to be
a wife the man that I want can't can't
care about who the [__] I went on it who
I did what with and that's that's what's
really destructive about feminism is
that you talk about female empowerment
and then you guys bring each other down
more than men do you just compared
motherhood to breeding being bred like a
child these women have to go to sleep at
night how many how many women have we
seen Instagram models right now which
any woman to think who were the
Instagram models busting it open it or
getting married what happens when if of
all the electricity were to go out and
all the police were to quit this would
become a violent place very quickly and
there would be [__] zero feminists
left zero
zero need men that's the bottom line of
reality